The Dazzled This Holiday Season by Northern Virginia's largest drive-through light show at Bull Run Festival of Lights. Celebrate the holidays as a family, while staying warm and cozy. Drive the festival route from the comfort of your car. Turn off your headlights and just follow the magical glow through two and a half miles of dazzling displays. In Bull Run Regional Park in Centralville, Virginia, plan your visit now. When you visit by mid-December, you'll see. Get your tickets today at bullrunfestivaloflights.com. That's bullrunfestivaloflights.com. When two friends go missing back-to-back, and in between their disappearances, a third friend is murdered, their mothers are the first to find connections between the three
在这个节日季，弗吉尼亚州北部最大的免下车灯光秀——布尔润灯光节（Bull Run Festival of Lights）将让您眼花缭乱。在保持温暖舒适的同时，与家人一起庆祝节日。在车内舒适地行驶在节日路线上。关掉车头灯，跟随神奇的光芒穿过两英里半的炫目展示。计划您现在就前往位于弗吉尼亚州森特维尔的布尔润地区公园（Bull Run Regional Park）的行程。如果您在12月中旬前参观，您就会明白。今天就在 bullrunfestivaloflights.com 购票。网址是 bullrunfestivaloflights.com。当两位朋友接连失踪，而在他们失踪期间，第三位朋友被谋杀时，他们的母亲是第一批发现这三起案件之间联系的人。
cases. Along with a local crime reporter, they begin an investigation that unearthed heartbreaking revelations, which no one was prepared for. This is the story behind the Bakersfield 3, the latest original podcast from Case File Presents. This series is the culmination of five years of reporting, research and interviews by award-winning journalist Olivia LaVois. The Bakersfield 3 features exclusive interviews with key players as crucial events unfolded. Listeners will also hear audio from police interrogations, jailhouse phone calls, an explosive
连同当地的一名犯罪记者，她们开始了一项调查，揭开了令人心碎的真相，而没有人对此做好准备。这就是“贝克斯菲尔德3人组”（Bakersfield 3）背后的故事，这是 Case File Presents 推出的最新原创播客。该系列是获奖记者奥利维亚·拉沃伊斯（Olivia LaVois）五年报道、研究和采访的结晶。“贝克斯菲尔德3人组”专题节目包含对关键人物在关键事件展开时的独家采访。听众还将听到来自警方审讯、监狱电话、一场爆炸性
trial, and more. This is like no story you've ever heard before. The entire Bakersfield 3 series is available now. Listen to all 15 episodes of the Bakersfield 3, wherever you get your podcasts. Stay tuned to the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often-distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis center.
审判等的音频。这就像您以前从未听过的任何故事。整个“贝克斯菲尔德3人组”系列现已上线。无论您在哪里收听播客，都可以收听“贝克斯菲尔德3人组”的所有15集。请收听今天节目的结尾以收听预告片。我们的剧集涉及严重且通常令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。
For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the telephone rang at the Southern California home of Jack Martin. A contractor by trade, Jack was at work, so the call was answered by his teenage daughter, Bonnie. Not immediately recognizing the female voice on the other end of the line, Bonnie asked, who is this?
有关保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请参阅电话铃声在杰克·马丁（Jack Martin）位于南加州的家中响起。杰克是一名职业承包商，当时正在工作，所以电话由他十几岁的女儿邦妮（Bonnie）接听。邦妮没有立即认出电话那头女人的声音，便问：“你是谁？”
The caller responded, Bonnie, it's your sister, it's Colleen. Bonnie was in shock. Her older sister, Colleen Stan, had inexplicably disappeared three years earlier, and her family hadn't spoken to her since. On the phone, Colleen sounded shaky and hurried. She reassured her younger sister that she was fine and staying up north with some friends.
打电话的人回答说：“邦妮，我是你姐姐，我是科琳（Colleen）。”邦妮惊呆了。她的姐姐科琳·斯坦（Colleen Stan）三年前莫名其妙地失踪了，从那以后她的家人就再也没有和她说过话。电话里，科琳的声音颤抖而匆忙。她安慰妹妹说她很好，正和一些朋友住在北方。
She didn't elaborate and was evasive when Bonnie asked for more information, but the call sparked a lot of emotion, bringing both sisters to tears. Colleen asked Bonnie how each member of their family was doing. Bonnie broke the news that their aunt was dying of cancer. In the time Colleen had been away, their stepmother had also given birth. Colleen had a three-year-old half-sister she had never met. The long-awaited chat barely lasted five minutes before Colleen interrupted Bonnie, stating
她没有详细说明，当邦妮询问更多信息时，她闪烁其词，但这个电话引发了强烈的情绪，让姐妹俩都流下了眼泪。科琳问邦妮家里每个人的情况。邦妮告诉她，她们的姑姑患癌症快要去世了。在科琳离开的这段时间里，她们的继母也生了孩子。科琳有一个三岁的同父异母妹妹，她从未见过。期待已久的谈话只持续了不到五分钟，科琳就打断了邦妮，说
that she had to go right away. Bonnie pleaded with Colleen to call back later that night when their father would be home. Colleen replied quickly, tell everyone that I love and miss them, before hanging up. Prior to this call, the last contact anyone had with Colleen Stan was on Thursday May 19, 1977. The then 20-year-old lived in Eugene, Oregon and had spent the night at her boyfriend Mark's house. Early that morning, Mark drove Colleen back to her apartment. Colleen had a close friend named Linda who lived interstate in Westwood, California.
她必须马上走。邦妮恳求科琳晚些时候等父亲回家后再打回来。科琳很快回答说：“告诉大家我爱他们，想念他们”，然后挂断了电话。在此次通话之前，任何人与科琳·斯坦的最后一次联系是在1977年5月19日星期四。当时20岁的她住在俄勒冈州的尤金，在男友马克（Mark）家过夜。那天清晨，马克开车送科琳回她的公寓。科琳有一个好朋友叫琳达（Linda），住在加利福尼亚州的韦斯特伍德（Westwood）。
It was Linda's birthday and that weekend she was having a party at her home. The impulsive and free spirited Colleen wanted to surprise her friend by showing up at the party out of the blue. Mark was trepidacious. He felt the six and a half hour journey to Westwood was too far for Colleen to travel alone. Although Colleen understood her boyfriend's concerns, she was headstrong and independent and couldn't be dissuaded.
那天是琳达的生日，那个周末她在家里举办派对。冲动且自由奔放的科琳想给朋友一个惊喜，突然出现在派对上。马克很担心。他觉得去韦斯特伍德六个半小时的路程对科琳一个人来说太远了。虽然科琳理解男友的担忧，但她固执且独立，无法被劝阻。
She assured Mark that she'd be back by Sunday in time for a get-together his family was having. That same morning, Colleen told her roommates about her plan. There was just one problem. Colleen's car was unreliable and she didn't have enough money for public transportation. She had therefore decided to hitchhike. At the time, hitchhiking was a common means for cash-strapped youth to get around. Colleen had hitched rides around Eugene many times without incident.
她向马克保证，她会在周日赶回来，参加他家人举办的聚会。那天早上，科琳告诉了室友她的计划。只有一个问题。科琳的车不可靠，她也没有足够的钱乘坐公共交通工具。因此，她决定搭便车。当时，搭便车是缺钱的年轻人出行的一种常见方式。科琳曾在尤金周围多次搭便车，没有发生任何意外。
It was even how she'd met Mark. Although she'd never hitched as far as Westwood, Colleen was confident she could get there by nightfall without any issues. She asked her roommates if they could give her a lift to Interstate 5. The long stretch of highway curved southward into California and marked the first leg of Colleen's 400 mile journey. Like Mark, Colleen's roommates were apprehensive. Colleen told them, my mind is made up, thanks for your concerns, but I'm going.
这甚至就是她遇见马克的方式。虽然她从未搭便车去过韦斯特伍德那么远的地方，但科琳相信她可以在天黑前毫无问题地到达那里。她问室友能不能送她去5号州际公路。那条漫长的高速公路向南弯曲进入加利福尼亚州，标志着科琳400英里旅程的第一段。和马克一样，科琳的室友也很担心。科琳告诉他们：“我心意已决，谢谢你们的关心，但我一定要去。”
Colleen stuffed some spare clothes into her sleeping bag and grabbed her purse. Her roommates reluctantly drove her to interstate five, all the while urging her to rethink her plan. But Colleen couldn't be swayed. Certain she'd be safe, she got out at the shoulder of the highway and bid her roommates goodbye. On Sunday, Colleen failed to show up at Mark's family get together. There had been no word from her since she spontaneously left for California three days earlier.
科琳把一些备用衣服塞进睡袋，抓起钱包。室友们不情愿地开车送她到5号州际公路，一路上催促她重新考虑她的计划。但科琳无法被动摇。确信自己会很安全，她在高速公路路肩下车，向室友告别。周日，科琳没有出现在马克的家庭聚会上。自从她三天前自发前往加利福尼亚以来，就再也没有她的消息。
Colleen's friends soon learned that she never even reached Westwood, nor had she contacted the birthday girl Linda. Colleen's family in Riverside, which was a further 10 hours south, hadn't heard from her either. A missing person's report was swiftly filed. There were no clues along Colleen's intended route to indicate where she might have gone. She didn't have any known ties between Eugene and Westwood that might have diverted her. Having left no hints about her current whereabouts, it was as though Colleen stand simply vanished
科琳的朋友们很快得知她甚至从未到达韦斯特伍德，也没有联系过寿星琳达。科琳在里弗赛德（Riverside）的家人（向南还有10小时路程）也没有收到她的消息。失踪人口报告很快被提交。在科琳预定的路线上没有任何线索表明她可能去了哪里。她在尤金和韦斯特伍德之间没有任何已知的联系人可能会让她改道。由于没有留下关于她目前下落的任何暗示，科琳·斯坦就像是凭空消失了一样。
into thin air. The situation was grossly out of character for Colleen, a happy and caring young woman who always stayed in touch with her friends and family. Colleen was particularly close to her father, Jack. Three weeks after her disappearance, father's day came and went with no contact from Colleen, further escalating concerns for her well-being. By this point, the police had failed to uncover any leads in their search for the 20-year-old. All the while, Colleen's loved ones agonized over the enduring mystery, unsure what to think.
这种情况对于科琳来说非常反常，她是一个快乐且充满爱心的年轻女性，总是与朋友和家人保持联系。科琳与她的父亲杰克特别亲近。她失踪三周后，父亲节到了，但科琳没有任何联系，这进一步加剧了人们对她安危的担忧。到目前为止，警方在寻找这位20岁女孩的过程中没有发现任何线索。与此同时，科琳的亲人们为这个持久的谜团感到痛苦，不知道该想些什么。
As years began to pass, Colleen's loved ones wondered whether she had fallen victim to one of the many cults prevalent in California at the time, or some other group that restricted her contact with the outside world. Perhaps she'd broken the law and was on the run. If she had voluntarily run away, there was little the police could do. Colleen was an adult and free to do whatever she pleased. It was three years into Colleen's disappearance that she suddenly called home
随着岁月流逝，科琳的亲人们想知道她是否成为了当时在加利福尼亚流行的众多邪教之一的受害者，或者其他限制她与外界联系的团体。也许她触犯了法律，正在逃亡。如果她是自愿离家出走，警方能做的就很少了。科琳是一个成年人，可以自由地做她想做的任何事情。在科琳失踪三年后，她突然打了个电话回家，
and spoke with her younger sister, Bonnie. Bonnie rushed to her father's work site and gave him the good news. Jack Martin was thrilled to learn Colleen had finally reached out. He finished early and went home, eagerly waiting for Colleen to call back. But the night passed with no further contact from her. The telephone company traced Colleen's call to a payphone at a gas station in Chico, a Californian city just 40 miles southeast from Jack's residence in Riverside.
并与她的妹妹邦妮交谈。邦妮冲到父亲的工作地点，把这个好消息告诉了他。杰克·马丁得知科琳终于联系上了，感到非常激动。他提前下班回家，焦急地等待科琳回电。但夜晚过去了，她没有再联系。电话公司追踪到科琳的电话来自奇科（Chico）一家加油站的公用电话，奇科是加利福尼亚州的一个城市，距离杰克在里弗赛德的住所仅40英里。
Home to California State University, Chico was populated by many young people. But as far as Colleen's family were aware, Colleen had no connection to the area. They couldn't think of any reason why she would be there. After the call, Colleen's family began receiving handwritten letters from Colleen with the Chico postmarks. All were brief and scanned in detail, merely saying she was living with a family and taking care of their children. In one letter, Colleen detailed her new interest in gardening.
奇科是加州州立大学的所在地，居住着许多年轻人。但据科琳的家人所知，科琳与该地区没有任何联系。他们想不出她为什么会在那里。通话后，科琳的家人开始收到科琳从奇科寄来的手写信件。所有信件都很简短，细节模糊，只是说她和一个家庭住在一起，照顾他们的孩子。在一封信中，科琳详细介绍了她对园艺的新兴趣。
She explained that she'd taken up keening fruit as a hobby and even included a few recipes. However, she never provided a return address or any other means for her family to get in touch. On Christmas Eve of 1980, Jack Martin received another phone call from Colleen. Again, she kept the conversation brief and non-specific. When Jack asked for her phone number so they could speak again, Colleen hesitantly replied, this is not my phone. I will give it to you some other time. Jack asked when she'd be coming home.
她解释说她把制作水果罐头作为一种爱好，甚至还附上了几个食谱。然而，她从未提供回信地址或任何其他让家人联系她的方式。1980年平安夜，杰克·马丁接到了科琳的另一个电话。同样，她保持谈话简短且不具体。当杰克询问她的电话号码以便他们再次交谈时，科琳犹豫地回答说：“这不是我的电话。我以后会给你的。”杰克问她什么时候回家。
Colleen replied soon before ending the call. Not long after, a box arrived at Jack's home. It was a Christmas present from Colleen for her newborn half-sister, a hand-made blanket. Three months later, on the night of Friday, March 20, 1981, there was a knock at Jack Martin's front door. Outside, stood the now 24-year-old Colleen Stan, alone with nothing but a small suitcase that hold a few items of clothing and some handmade gifts for her family. Colleen's physical appearance was as shocking as her unexpected arrival.
科琳回答说“很快”，然后结束了通话。没过多久，一个包裹寄到了杰克家。那是科琳送给她刚出生的同父异母妹妹的圣诞礼物，一条手工制作的毯子。三个月后，1981年3月20日星期五晚上，杰克·马丁的前门响起了敲门声。门外站着现年24岁的科琳·斯坦，独自一人，只带着一个小手提箱，里面装着几件衣服和一些送给家人的手工礼物。科琳的外表和她意想不到的到来一样令人震惊。
The last time her family had seen her, she'd been healthy and glowing. Now she looked tired with dark circles around her sunken eyes. Her skin was pale and her once long thick blonde hair was short, dull and thin. Her maid clothes sunk from her gorn frame. For the first time in almost four years, Jack pulled Colleen into a long-awaited warm embrace. He couldn't help but notice how bonny she was. The home was soon a buzz with family members who rushed over to reconnect with Colleen, including her mother, stepmother, sisters and step siblings. They bombarded Colleen
家人上次见到她时，她健康且容光焕发。现在她看起来很疲惫，深陷的眼睛周围有黑眼圈。她的皮肤苍白，曾经又长又厚的金发变得短、暗淡且稀疏。她的衣服挂在她消瘦的骨架上。近四年来，杰克第一次把科琳拉进了一个期待已久的温暖拥抱中。他不禁注意到她有多么瘦弱。家里很快就挤满了赶来与科琳重新团聚的家庭成员，包括她的母亲、继母、姐妹和继兄弟姐妹。他们用拥抱和亲吻轰炸科琳，
with hugs and kisses while filling her in on everything she'd missed. They were cautious not to interrogate her, mindful that whatever had kept Colleen from them might be something she wasn't ready to address or couldn't speak about at all. If they pushed her too soon, she might disappear again. Instead, they made Colleen feel as loved and cared for as possible, while waiting patiently for her to broach the topic herself. But she revealed nothing. That night, Colleen stayed up until 2am, reminiscing with her now 21-year-old sister, Bonnie.
同时向她讲述她错过的一切。他们小心翼翼地不去审问她，意识到无论是什么让科琳远离他们，可能都是她还没准备好面对或根本无法谈论的事情。如果他们逼得太紧，她可能会再次消失。相反，他们尽可能让科琳感到被爱和被照顾，同时耐心地等待她自己提出这个话题。但她什么也没透露。那天晚上，科琳一直待到凌晨2点，与她现在21岁的妹妹邦妮叙旧。
Within the safety of their sisterly bond and away from the others, Bonnie began seriously pressing Colleen about why she to suddenly ceased contact. Colleen hesitated before explaining that she couldn't afford to make calls and had been too busy working and babysitting. This answer further solidified Bonnie's suspicion that Colleen had become involved with a nefarious cult that forced her to surrender all her money and prevented her from contacting anyone outside their circle. The following morning, Colleen was given freshly ironed clothes so she could
在姐妹情谊的安全感中，远离其他人，邦妮开始认真追问科琳为什么突然停止联系。科琳犹豫了一下，解释说她负担不起打电话的费用，而且一直忙于工作和照顾孩子。这个回答进一步巩固了邦妮的怀疑，即科琳卷入了一个邪恶的邪教，强迫她交出所有的钱，并阻止她联系圈子外的任何人。第二天早上，科琳换上了熨烫整齐的衣服，以便她能
attend a church with her grandmother who had been praying for Colleen's safe return. Afterwards, Colleen's family took her to a nearby town to visit her cancer-stricken aunt, and then they all went out for lunch. When they later returned to the family home in Riverside, the phone rang. Colleen answered. She told the caller, yes sir, before hanging up. Her mood was now somber. Ten minutes later there was a knock at the front door. Standing there was a tall, gaunt man who looked a little older than Colleen. He had greasy, light-brown hair
和一直为科琳平安归来祈祷的祖母一起去教堂。之后，科琳的家人带她去附近的一个城镇探望她患癌症的姑姑，然后他们一起出去吃午饭。当他们后来回到里弗赛德的家中时，电话响了。科琳接了电话。她对打电话的人说：“是的，先生”，然后挂断了电话。她的心情现在变得阴郁。十分钟后，前门响起了敲门声。站在那里的是一个高大、憔悴的男人，看起来比科琳大一点。他留着油腻的浅棕色头发，
combed to one side, with sideburns framing his oily face and a pair of aviator-style reading glasses perched on his nose. He introduced himself as Mike and announced that he had come to pick up Colleen. Mike told Colleen's family that the pair had met several months earlier and were now engaged to be married. He explained that he was in the computer business and had been attending a seminar nearby, enabling Colleen to drop in to see her family. But now they needed to get back on the road. Colleen's family asked for a phone number so they could keep in touch.
梳向一边，鬓角勾勒出他油腻的脸，鼻梁上架着一副飞行员风格的阅读眼镜。他自我介绍叫迈克（Mike），并宣布他是来接科琳的。迈克告诉科琳的家人，两人几个月前相识，现在已经订婚。他解释说他在从事计算机行业，一直在附近参加研讨会，这让科琳有机会顺道探望家人。但现在他们需要重新上路了。科琳的家人询问电话号码以便保持联系。
Stuttering somewhat, Mike said that they didn't have one as they were in the process of moving to Oregon. He assured the group he'd provide a number once they'd settled. Bonnie was dubious. From the moment Mike entered the room, the spark in Colleen's eyes faded. In the past, Colleen was always very affectionate towards her boyfriend. Around Mike, she was cool and distant. In another room, Bonnie told her stepmother,
迈克有些结巴地说，他们没有电话，因为他们正在搬往俄勒冈州。他向大家保证，一旦安顿下来，他会提供一个号码。邦妮很怀疑。从迈克走进房间的那一刻起，科琳眼中的光芒就消失了。过去，科琳对男友总是非常深情。在迈克身边，她显得冷漠而疏远。在另一个房间里，邦妮告诉她的继母：
I'm not going to let Colleen leave until I find out what's going on. I will block the door with my body if I have to. Her stepmother urged her to settle down, worried any antagonistic display would push Colleen away for good. Prior to leaving, Colleen posed for several photos with her family before it was suggested she take one with Mike. She draped her arms around her fiance, rested her head on his shoulder and smiled for the camera.
“在弄清楚发生了什么之前，我不会让科琳离开。如果必须的话，我会用身体挡住门。”她的继母催促她冷静下来，担心任何对抗性的表现都会把科琳彻底推开。离开前，科琳和家人拍了几张照片，然后有人建议她和迈克拍一张。她搂住未婚夫，把头靠在他的肩膀上，对着镜头微笑。
She then hugged her family goodbye, telling them she loved them. At 7pm, barely 24 hours after she'd reappeared, Colleen's den was gone again. Despite the whirlwind visit, Colleen's family were delighted to have finally seen her. Yet, Bonnie remained uneasy. Throughout their conversations, Bonnie had sensed that Colleen wanted to tell her something. Whatever it was, had remained unsaid. Four years earlier, Colleen stand began her solo hitchhike to California. Within five minutes of waiting alongside Interstate 5 in Oregon, she got her first ride. A young college student driving a sports car was willing to take her as far as he could,
然后她拥抱家人告别，告诉他们她爱他们。晚上7点，在科琳重新出现不到24小时后，她又走了。尽管这次访问如旋风般短暂，但科琳的家人很高兴终于见到了她。然而，邦妮仍然感到不安。在他们的谈话中，邦妮感觉到科琳想告诉她什么。无论那是什么，都一直没有说出口。四年前，科琳·斯坦开始了她独自搭便车前往加利福尼亚的旅程。在俄勒冈州5号州际公路旁等待了不到五分钟，她就搭上了第一辆车。一名开着跑车的年轻大学生愿意载她尽可能远，
which was a little ways south to Cottage Grove. It barely shaved 20 miles off of Colleen's long journey, but it was progress nonetheless. From there, Colleen was quickly picked up again, this time by a semi-truck driver. He agreed to take her to Red Bluff, a Californian city a few hours south. As they drove along, the truck driver attempted to grope Colleen. She pushed him away and shouted for him to leave her alone, successfully putting an end to his unwanted advance. It was around 4pm by the time she reached Red Bluff, having travelled for a little over
也就是往南一点到小屋树林（Cottage Grove）。这几乎没有缩短科琳漫长旅程的20英里，但无论如何都是一种进展。从那里，科琳很快又搭上了一辆车，这次是一名半挂卡车司机。他同意带她去红崖（Red Bluff），一个在南边几个小时路程的加利福尼亚城市。当他们开车时，卡车司机试图猥亵科琳。她把他推开并大喊让他离她远点，成功结束了他的不轨企图。当她到达红崖时，时间大约是下午4点，她已经旅行了
5 hours. Her final destination was less than 100 miles east. She was on track to reach Westwood before days end, just as she'd hoped. Colleen stood on the side of the highway 36 overpass above Interstate 5 with her thumb out. Soon, a car full of hippie-like young men stopped alongside her. Colleen's guard was up after her encounter with the CD truck driver. Dean's guard was up after her encounter with the CD truck driver. She carefully assessed the situation and concluded that it wasn't smart for her to be alone in a car with five men.
5个多小时。她的最终目的地在东边不到100英里处。她正按计划在天黑前到达韦斯特伍德，正如她所希望的那样。科琳站在5号州际公路上方36号高速公路立交桥的路边，伸出大拇指。很快，一辆坐满嬉皮士风格年轻人的车停在她身边。在经历了与那个猥琐卡车司机的遭遇后，科琳提高了警惕。她仔细评估了情况，认为自己一个人和五个男人待在一辆车里并不明智。
She thanked them before remarking, not today. The car spat off. Minutes later, a second car pulled up with a young couple inside. Though Colleen felt safer in their presence, they could only take her a short distance down the highway, so she declined to there offer too. The next card to stop was a cobalt blue 2-door 1971 Dodge Colt with a young man behind the wheel. In the passenger seat was a young woman with a baby girl cradled in her arms.
她感谢了他们，然后说：“今天不行。”车开走了。几分钟后，第二辆车停了下来，里面是一对年轻夫妇。虽然科琳在他们面前感到更安全，但他们只能带她走一小段高速公路，所以她也拒绝了他们的提议。下一辆停下来的车是一辆钴蓝色双门1971年道奇柯尔特（Dodge Colt），驾驶座上是一名年轻男子。副驾驶座上是一名年轻女子，怀里抱着一个女婴。
The woman wound down her window to ask Colleen where she was going. Westwood, Colleen replied, The driver said that they were heading that way and offered to take Colleen with them. Once again, Colleen assessed the situation. The couple were an unremarkable working-class pair. The man looked to be in his early 20s and judging by his outfit, he was likely a manual laborer who'd spent the day toiling. His jeans, shirt and boots were dirty, his blonde hair greasy, and he smelled of sweat.
那个女人摇下车窗问科琳要去哪里。“韦斯特伍德，”科琳回答。司机说他们正往那个方向去，并主动提出带科琳一起走。科琳再次评估了情况。这对夫妇是一对普通的工人阶级。男人看起来20出头，从他的装束来看，他很可能是一名辛苦工作了一天的体力劳动者。他的牛仔裤、衬衫和靴子都很脏，金发油腻，身上散发着汗味。
Both the man and woman wore eye glasses, but the woman was a few years younger. She had a long black hair and was dressed casually in shorts and a t-shirt. The little girl in her lap was a little under a year old. Her presence re-assured Colleen, who squeezed in behind the passenger seat, thanking the couple for their kindness. As they drove on, their surroundings became more remote. Colleen glimpsed the driver's eyes as he kept staring back at her in the rear-view mirror. They asked why she was heading to Westwood.
男人和女人都戴着眼镜，但女人年轻几岁。她留着长长的黑发，穿着休闲的短裤和T恤。她怀里的小女孩不到一岁。她的存在让科琳感到安心，科琳挤进副驾驶座后面，感谢这对夫妇的善意。随着他们继续行驶，周围的环境变得越来越偏僻。科琳瞥见司机的眼睛，他一直通过后视镜盯着她看。他们问她为什么要前往韦斯特伍德。
Colleen explained it was to surprise a friend for her birthday. She doesn't know you are coming, the man asked, prompting Colleen to respond, no, it will be a complete surprise. He began peppering her with questions, asking if she hitchhiked often and whether she was married. Colleen was tired and quickly grew weary of his interest in her personal life, but she didn't want to be rude so she answered each question briefly. Despite everything the couple learned about Colleen, they didn't tell her a single fact
科琳解释说是为了给朋友一个生日惊喜。“她不知道你要来吗？”男人问，促使科琳回答：“不，这将是一个完全的惊喜。”他开始连珠炮似地问她问题，问她是否经常搭便车，是否结婚了。科琳很累，很快就厌倦了他对她私生活的兴趣，但她不想表现得粗鲁，所以她简短地回答了每一个问题。尽管这对夫妇了解了关于科琳的一切，但他们没有告诉她任何关于他们自己的事实。
about themselves. They drove for less than half an hour before the men announced they needed to stop the gas. He pulled into a station in Paine's Creek, a quaint rest stop among farmlands. Colleen headed to the bathroom to freshen up. While splashing herself with cool water, she was suddenly overwhelmed by an instinct to run and never look back. Colleen's attention was drawn to a small window that led outside. Her internal voice urged her to crawl out of it and run. Colleen didn't know what to make of these disturbing feelings.
他们开了不到半小时，男人就宣布他们需要停下来加油。他开进佩恩溪（Paine's Creek）的一个加油站，这是一个农田间古朴的休息站。科琳去洗手间梳洗。当她用凉水泼脸时，她突然被一种逃跑且永不回头的本能所淹没。科琳的注意力被一扇通往外面的小窗户吸引了。她内心的声音催促她爬出去逃跑。科琳不知道该如何看待这些令人不安的感觉。
She left the restroom and was immediately met by the smiling couple who offered her some candy. This quelled the peculiar feeling of dread bubbling away inside of her. Westwood was less than an hour away. All Colleen could think about was getting there before nightfall. The group got back into the car and drove eastward, but something odd drew Colleen's attention. On the seat next to her was a wooden cube shaped box that she hadn't noticed before. It measured about a foot on each side and featured several metal hinges and leather reinforcement straps. Having no idea what it
她离开洗手间，立刻遇到了微笑着的夫妇，他们给了她一些糖果。这平息了她内心涌动的奇怪恐惧感。韦斯特伍德距离不到一小时路程。科琳满脑子想的都是在天黑前到达那里。一行人回到车里继续向东行驶，但一些奇怪的事情引起了科琳的注意。她旁边的座位上有一个木制的立方体盒子，她之前没注意到。它每边大约一英尺长，带有几个金属铰链和皮革加固带。不知道它
was or could be used for, Colleen disregarded it. Beyond Paine's Creek, the sparsely populated farming landscape transformed into dense, uninhabited pine forest that loomed over the now isolated stretch of highway. The man said there were some ice caves nearby that he'd heard about. He asked if it would be alright if they stopped for a bit to check them out. It was now approaching 5pm. Colleen was concerned they wouldn't make it to Westwood before dark, but the couple It was now approaching 5pm. Colleen was concerned they wouldn't make it to Westwood before dark, but the couple
是什么或有什么用途，科琳没理会它。在佩恩溪之外，人口稀少的农耕景观变成了茂密、无人居住的松树林，笼罩在现在孤立的高速公路路段上。男人说附近有一些他听说过的冰洞。他问如果他们停下来看一看是否可以。现在接近下午5点。科琳担心他们无法在天黑前到达韦斯特伍德，但这对夫妇
assured her they would. Not wanting to be ungrateful, she reluctantly accepted their new plan. They headed down an unmarked dirt road and about a quarter of a mile into the forest before the man stopped the car. Colleen hadn't seen any signs indicating the direction of the ice caves, but trusted the couple knew where they were going. Not wanting to prolong the visit, she opted to stay behind as the couple got out with their baby and headed towards a nearby creek.
向她保证他们会到达。不想表现得不知好歹，她不情愿地接受了他们的新计划。他们沿着一条未标记的土路行驶，进入森林约四分之一英里，然后男人停下了车。科琳没有看到任何指示冰洞方向的标志，但相信这对夫妇知道他们要去哪里。不想延长访问时间，她选择留在后面，因为这对夫妇带着他们的孩子走向附近的一条小溪。
The next time Colleen looked up, only the woman and baby were standing there. The man had vanished. Suddenly, the man leapt into the back seat and pressed the butcher's knife to Colleen's throat, ordering her to put her hands above her head. Frozen in fear, Colleen couldn't believe what was happening. Within seconds,
科琳下次抬头时，只有那个女人和孩子站在那里。男人消失了。突然，男人跳进后座，把一把屠夫刀抵在科琳的喉咙上，命令她把双手举过头顶。科琳惊恐万分，不敢相信正在发生的事情。几秒钟内，
her hands were handcuffed behind her back. The man asked, are you going to do as I tell you? A adrenaline pumping, Colleen was too overwhelmed to speak and could only nod. A blindfold was placed over her eyes before something was harnessed tightly around her head that secured a wide leather strap across her mouth, gagging her. Her ankles were then tied together with robe. Everything the man did was so swift, precise and purposeful, Colleen sands had been planning and practicing it for some time. A heavy object that felt like it weighed about 20 pounds was forced over Colleen's head,
她的双手被反铐在背后。男人问：“你会按我说的做吗？”肾上腺素飙升，科琳太震惊了，说不出话来，只能点头。一个眼罩蒙住了她的眼睛，然后某种东西紧紧地系在她的头上，固定住一条横跨她嘴巴的宽皮带，堵住了她的嘴。她的脚踝随后被绳子绑在一起。男人所做的一切都如此迅速、精确且有目的，科琳·斯坦意识到他已经计划并练习了很长一段时间。一个感觉重约20磅的重物被强行套在科琳的头上，
contoured to the exact shape of her skull. She realised it was the strange wooden box from the back seat. The inside was lined with foam rubber and carpet, blocking out light, sound and air, creating a suffocating sensation. The box snapped shut and was locked so tightly around Colleen's neck that she felt like she was being strangled. As she lay completely restrained in the back seat, her sleeping bag was then spread out on top of her.
轮廓与她头骨的形状完全吻合。她意识到那是后座上那个奇怪的木箱。内部衬有泡沫橡胶和地毯，阻挡了光线、声音和空气，产生了一种窒息感。盒子猛地关上，紧紧地锁在科琳的脖子上，让她感觉自己快要被勒死了。当她完全被束缚在后座上时，她的睡袋被铺在她身上。
Sweltering under the sleeping bag and inside the stifling head box, Colleen feared she'd die of heatstroke. From the muffled sounds around her, Colleen deduced that the woman and her daughter were back inside the car. An additional weight was placed on top of Colleen's body. It was the baby. Colleen felt the car take off. After a short bumpy ride, they re-emerged on the highway and wound along the mountainous
在睡袋下和闷热的头箱里，科琳担心自己会死于中暑。从她周围闷响的声音中，科琳推断出那个女人和她的女儿回到了车里。一个额外的重量被放在科琳的身体上。那是婴儿。科琳感觉到车开动了。经过一段颠簸的短途行驶后，他们重新出现在高速公路上，沿着多山的
road. they re-emerged on the highway and wound along the mountainous route. In time, Colleen heard the barely audible sounds of passing traffic and town life. They were back amongst civilization. The cast sped, veered and circled in many directions before finally coming to a stop. The sleeping bag was lifted off Colleen, and finally, the wooden box was removed from her head. The rush of cool air was exhilarating. Colleen's blindfold and other restraints were kept on as she was forced to sit up. Her captors were eating hamburgers and fries, which Colleen assumed must have come from a drive-through restaurant. While she had no real comprehension of where they were, she knew it had to be somewhere private
路线行驶。过了一会儿，科琳听到了过往车辆和城镇生活的微弱声音。他们回到了文明社会。车子加速、转向并向多个方向盘旋，最后停了下来。睡袋从科琳身上移开，最后，木箱从她头上取下。凉爽空气的涌入令人振奋。科琳的眼罩和其他束缚物被保留着，她被迫坐起来。她的绑架者正在吃汉堡和薯条，科琳推测这一定来自一家免下车餐厅。虽然她对他们身在何处没有任何真正的理解，但她知道这一定是一个私密的地方，
for the couple to be bold enough to consume a meal without concern. Struck by their nonchalance, Colleen began plotting an escape. She barely had time to consider anything worthwhile before she was forced to lie back down. The wooden box was clamped back over her head, removing any possibility of a getaway for now. They drove for a while before stopping again. This time, the man removed the wooden box and the rope from around Colleen's ankles but kept the handcuffs a blindfold and a gag in place. Sit up, he ordered. He asked if she would do what she was told. Colleen gave a muffled yes from behind her gag.
这对夫妇才敢大胆地吃一顿饭而不担心。被他们的冷漠所震惊，科琳开始策划逃跑。她还没来得及考虑任何有价值的事情，就被迫躺下。木箱再次被夹在她的头上，消除了目前逃跑的任何可能性。他们开了一会儿车，然后再次停下。这次，男人取下了木箱和绑在科琳脚踝上的绳子，但保留了手铐、眼罩和口塞。“坐起来，”他命令道。他问她是否会按吩咐去做。科琳在口塞后面发出了闷声的“是”。
She was told to get out of the car. Through a slight gap in her blindfold, she could tell it was nighttime. The man gripped Colleen's shoulders and pushed her up a set of porch steps to what she figured was the back door of her house. Inside, the glimpse of a stove indicated she was in a kitchen. Colleen was taken through another door and down a steep flight of 14 wooden stairs into a cold, dusty basement. She was tormented by the question, what are these people going to do to me? Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Too busy achieving all your day-to-day goals to cook, but want to make sure you're reading
她被告知下车。通过眼罩的一条小缝，她能看出是晚上了。男人抓住科琳的肩膀，把她推上一组门廊台阶，到了她认为是房子后门的地方。里面，炉子的瞥见表明她在厨房里。科琳被带过另一扇门，走下陡峭的14级木楼梯，进入一个寒冷、尘土飞扬的地下室。她被这个问题折磨着：“这些人要对我做什么？”Case File 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本节目的赞助商来支持我们。太忙于实现所有日常目标而无法做饭，但想确保您吃得
well? With Factor, skip the extra trip to the grocery store and the chopping, prepping and cleaning up too, while still getting the flavor and nutritional quality you need. Factor's fresh, never frozen meals are ready in just two minutes, so all you have to do is heat and enjoy, then get back to crushing your goals. Factor is America's number one ready-to-eat milk kit, and with meals delivered straight to your door, you'll save time, eat well, and stay on track with your healthy lifestyle. Choose from over 34 weekly flavor pack to dietician-approved meals and level up with gourmet
好吗？有了 Factor，跳过额外的杂货店购物以及切菜、准备和清理工作，同时仍然获得您需要的风味和营养质量。Factor 的新鲜、从不冷冻的餐点只需两分钟即可准备好，所以您所要做的就是加热并享用，然后回到实现您的目标中去。Factor 是美国排名第一的即食餐包，餐点直接送到您家门口，您将节省时间、吃得好，并保持健康的饮食习惯。从超过34种每周风味十足、营养师认可的餐点中进行选择，并升级到美食
plus options, prepared to perfection by chefs and ready to eat in record time. Treat yourself to upscale meals with premium ingredients like broccoli, leeks, truffle butter and asparagus. Case file team member Rotavia tells me that factor meals are like something you'd expect to eat at a fancy restaurant. Her favorite is the vegetarian green chili tostada bake with corn, salsa and sour cream, but she also loves the fruit smoothies for a quick on the go meal. Head to factameals.com slash case file 50 and use code case file 50 to get 50% off. That's code case file 50 at facta meals.com slash case file 50 to get 50% off. As the year wraps up, things start getting busy. You might be looking for wholesome convenient meals for jam packed days.
加选项，由厨师完美准备，并以创纪录的时间准备好食用。用西兰花、韭菜、松露黄油和芦笋等优质食材犒劳自己，享用高档餐点。Case File 团队成员阿塔维亚（Atavia）告诉我，Factor 的餐点就像您期望在高级餐厅吃到的东西。她最喜欢的是素食绿辣椒烤玉米饼，配玉米、莎莎酱和酸奶油，但她也喜欢水果冰沙，作为快速的随身餐点。前往 factameals.com/casefile50 并使用代码 casefile50 可获得50%的折扣。代码是 casefile50，网址是 factameals.com/casefile50，可获得50%的折扣。随着年底临近，事情开始变得忙碌。您可能正在为繁忙的日子寻找健康、方便的餐点。
Facta, America's number one ready to eat meal kit can help you fuel up fast for breakfast, lunch, and dinner, with chef-prepared, dietician-approved ready-to-eat meals delivered straight to your door. You'll save time, eat well, and stay on track with your healthy lifestyle. Choose from over 35 weekly flavor-packed, fresh, never-, never frozen meals that promote a healthy lifestyle and meet your meal preferences, already to eat in 2 minutes. Try factors for flavors, a limited time menu offering hardy, company meals featuring seasonal veggies like cranberry, pecan chicken and chicken, and apple, dejon pork chops. They'll satisfy your cravings during the busy season without the hassle,
Factor，美国排名第一的即食餐包，可以帮助您快速补充早餐、午餐和晚餐的能量，厨师准备、营养师认可的即食餐点直接送到您家门口。您将节省时间、吃得好，并保持健康的饮食习惯。从超过35种每周风味十足、新鲜、从不冷冻的餐点中进行选择，这些餐点促进健康的生活方式并满足您的饮食偏好，2分钟即可食用。尝试 Factor 的风味，这是一个限时菜单，提供丰盛、令人满意的餐点，特色是季节性蔬菜，如蔓越莓山核桃鸡和鸡肉，以及苹果第戎猪排。它们将在繁忙的季节满足您的渴望，而无需麻烦，
and round out your meals and replenish your snack supply with an assortment of over 45 addons to suit various preferences and tastes. Case file team member Atavia tells me that factor meals are like something you'd expect to eat at a fancy restaurant. Her favorite is the vegetarian green chili tostider bake with corn, salsa and sour cream. One of her meals featured a side of cauliflower rice, which a Tavia says is the best she's ever had. Head to factor meals.com slash case file 50 and slash casefile50 to get 50% off. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content.
并完善您的餐点并补充您的零食供应，提供超过45种附加选项，以满足各种偏好和口味。Case File 团队成员阿塔维亚告诉我，Factor 的餐点就像您期望在高级餐厅吃到的东西。她最喜欢的是素食绿辣椒烤玉米饼，配玉米、莎莎酱和酸奶油。她的一顿餐点配有花椰菜饭，阿塔维亚说这是她吃过的最好的。前往 factameals.com/casefile50 并使用 casefile50 可获得50%的折扣。感谢您收听本节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 CaseFile 继续提供高质量的内容。
Colleen was left alone with the men who ordered her to stand on top of an icebox. Colleen's handcuffs were then replaced with stiff leather straps, which were attached to something above. She could feel her captors hands shaking with excitement as he removed her shoes and stripped off her clothes. Through the slit in her blindfold, Colleen could see that the concrete basement was dimly lit by a single light bulb with two small windows high up on an adjacent wall. The windows were covered in black plastic. The space was
科琳被留下来与男人单独在一起，他命令她站在一个冰柜上。科琳的手铐随后被坚硬的皮带取代，皮带系在上面的某个东西上。她能感觉到绑架者的手因兴奋而颤抖，他脱掉了她的鞋子，剥去了她的衣服。通过眼罩的缝隙，科琳可以看到混凝土地下室被一盏昏暗的灯泡照亮，相邻的墙上有两扇小窗户。窗户上覆盖着黑色塑料。这个空间
around 14 feet long and 23 feet wide. Colleen was attached to a wooden beam that ran across the ceiling. Items hung from nails on one of the walls, but Colleen couldn't make out what they were. She spotted a magazine open on a wooden table before her. The pages featured an image of a naked woman strung up in the exact manner as Colleen. The man began running his hands over Colleen's naked body. With our warning, he then kicked to the icebox away, causing Colleen to drop into dangle in a wire shape.
长约14英尺，宽23英尺。科琳被系在横跨天花板的一根木梁上。物品挂在其中一面墙上的钉子上，但科琳看不出它们是什么。她发现面前的木桌上放着一本打开的杂志。页面上展示了一张裸体女性以与科琳完全相同的方式被吊起来的照片。男人开始用手抚摸科琳的裸体。没有警告，他随后踢开了冰柜，导致科琳掉落并悬挂成“Y”字形。
The weight of her hanging body caused immediate searing pain in her shoulders and wrists. Tears seeped into Colleen's blindfold as she violently thrashed her legs in a desperate, fruitless search for something to stand on. Naked, aching and trembling, Colleen sobbed as she thought, Why me, God? Realization dawned that no one in Westwood was expecting her, and therefore wouldn't be instigating a search. Colleen feared that by the time anyone figured out something was a miss, she would be dead.
悬挂身体的重量立即导致她的肩膀和手腕产生剧烈的灼痛。泪水渗入科琳的眼罩，她剧烈地挣扎着双腿，绝望而徒劳地寻找可以站立的东西。赤身裸体、疼痛且颤抖，科琳啜泣着想：“上帝啊，为什么是我？”她意识到韦斯特伍德没有人期待她，因此不会发起搜寻。科琳担心，当有人发现不对劲时，她可能已经死了。
The men went upstairs only to return a moment later with his female companion. They took off their clothes and began having sex on the table in front of Coling. Second, the full impact of her ordeal began to sink in as she struggled to comprehend exactly what sort of people she was now at the mercy of. Then, all of a sudden, she heard a crack. She was struck by a sharp, excruciating pain across her back. It happened again, this time against her stomach. She was being whipped over and over. Colleen realized the unidentifiable items she'd seen earlier on the wall were a collection of webs.
男人上楼了，片刻后带着他的女性同伴回来。他们脱掉衣服，开始在科琳面前的桌子上发生性关系。瞬间，她所经历的折磨的全部影响开始显现，她努力理解她现在到底是在什么样的人的摆布之下。然后，突然之间，她听到了一声脆响。她的背部感到一阵剧烈、难以忍受的疼痛。它再次发生，这次是在她的胃部。她被一遍又一遍地鞭打。科琳意识到她之前在墙上看到的无法辨认的物品是一系列鞭子。
Each struck produced unbearable pain unlike anything Colleen had ever experienced. It felt as though she was being assaulted right down to her soul. She flailed as the man barked at her to stop kicking, saying, it'll be over sooner. With great agony, Colleen made herself go limp, bringing the assault to a stop. A small box was placed under her feet, enough for her to stand awkwardly on her tiptoes and provide some much-needed relief. The couple resumed having sex. Once they were finished, the woman headed back upstairs, leaving Colleen alone with the
每一次抽打都产生了科琳从未经历过的难以忍受的痛苦。感觉就像她被袭击到了灵魂深处。当男人对她大喊停止踢腿时，她挣扎着，说：“快点结束吧。”在极度的痛苦中，科琳让自己瘫软下来，使袭击停止。一个小盒子被放在她的脚下，足以让她尴尬地踮着脚尖站立，并提供一些急需的缓解。这对夫妇恢复了性行为。当他们结束后，女人回到楼上，留下科琳与
man. He traced his fingers over the waltz the whip had left on her body, as though it amiring his work. Suddenly, the man kicked the box from under Colleen away, reigniting the fiery pain in her limbs. There were several flashes of light, and Colleen realized she was being photographed. The icebox was then returned under her feet, and the leather straps were removed from her wrists, allowing her to get down.
男人单独在一起。他用手指划过鞭子在她身上留下的伤痕，仿佛在欣赏他的作品。突然，男人把盒子从科琳脚下踢开，重新点燃了她四肢的火辣疼痛。有几次闪光，科琳意识到她正在被拍照。冰柜随后被放回她的脚下，皮带从她的手腕上取下，让她下来。
Colleen's hands were completely numb. The men pushed Colleen face first into a crate near the stairs. It was long enough for her to stretch her legs out, but too small for her to stand. Her ankles and wrists were chained to the crate, and the wooden soundproofed a box was once again secured around her head. Colleen was instantly consumed by the feeling of choking claustrophobia and began to hyperventilate. She screamed and fought desperately against the chains to no avail. Each breath felt like it could be her last.
科琳的手完全麻木了。男人把科琳脸朝下推入楼梯附近的一个板条箱里。它足够长，可以让她伸展双腿，但太小了，无法站立。她的脚踝和手腕被锁在板条箱上，木制的隔音箱再次被固定在她的头上。科琳瞬间被窒息的幽闭恐惧感所吞噬，开始过度换气。她尖叫着，绝望地与锁链搏斗，但无济于事。每一次呼吸都感觉像是她的最后一次。
After an indistinguishable amount of time, Colleen's distress was interrupted by the sensation of someone touching her winded back. She tanced as the head box was opened. It was her captor. What's wrong he asked? He's voice irritated and angry. She explained that she couldn't breathe and begged for her bruised wrists to be released. He replied, if you don't shut up I'll cut your vocal cords. I've done it before and I'll do it again. The head box was then reshield, sending Colleen back into the oppressive stifling darkness. rifling darkness. Colleen had no way of knowing whether she was ever left alone, but as the night wore on, she occasionally felt the man's touch.
在一段无法分辨长短的时间后，科琳的痛苦被背部被人触碰的感觉打断了。当头罩被打开时，她紧张起来。是她的绑架者。他问：“怎么了？”他的声音听起来既烦躁又愤怒。她解释说自己无法呼吸，并恳求他解开她淤青的手腕。他回答说：“如果你不闭嘴，我就割断你的声带。我以前做过，还会再做一次。”随后头罩被重新戴上，科琳再次陷入了压抑而窒息的黑暗中。科琳无法知道自己是否曾被单独留下，但随着夜色渐深，她偶尔能感觉到那个男人的触碰。
Her restraints prevented her from changing positions, and soon all her limbs went numb. Her lungs burned from struggling to breathe. The unrelenting discomfort prevented her from falling asleep. By morning, the basement was cold and Colleen was exhausted. The man removed the chains and head box but kept the blindfold and gag in place. Stand up, he commanded. Colleen struggled to her feet. The men grasped her by the shoulders and pushed her against the table where he and his partner had sex the night before.
她的束缚让她无法改变姿势，很快她的四肢就麻木了。她的肺部因为挣扎着呼吸而感到灼痛。持续不断的极度不适让她无法入睡。到了早上，地下室很冷，科琳精疲力竭。男人取下了锁链和头罩，但仍让她戴着眼罩和口塞。他命令道：“站起来。”科琳挣扎着站起身。男人抓住她的肩膀，把她推向桌子，那是他和他的同伙昨晚发生性关系的地方。
Climb up, he said. Too tired to fight, Colleen got up on the table, asking, when will you let me go? Soon he replied, as he positioned her to lie face up. The man referred to the wooden table as the rack. It measured 8 feet long, 3 feet wide, and 3 feet high, allowing him access to Colleen's body without having to bend over. Colleen was restrained to the table spread eagled in an X shape, with her wrists chained to the top
他说：“爬上去。”科琳太累了，无力反抗，她爬上桌子问道：“你们什么时候放我走？”他回答说：“很快。”同时让她平躺好。男人把这张木桌称为“刑架”。它长8英尺，宽3英尺，高3英尺，让他无需弯腰就能接触到科琳的身体。科琳被呈“X”形四肢张开地绑在桌子上，手腕被锁在顶部
corners and her ankles to the bottom. The sandproof box was then secured onto her head. Colleen waited nervously, but nothing happened. She finally found herself drifting off to sleep. By the time Colleen woke, she had no concept of time. She occupied her mind by reminiscing about her friends and boyfriend until the thoughts were interrupted by the head box being opened. Sit up, her captor demanded. It had been well over 24 hours since Colleen had drank,
角落，脚踝被锁在底部。隔音箱随后被固定在她的头上。科琳紧张地等待着，但什么也没发生。她最终昏昏沉沉地睡着了。当科琳醒来时，她对时间已经没有概念了。她通过回忆朋友和男朋友来打发时间，直到头罩被打开，思绪才被打断。她的绑架者命令道：“坐起来。”距离科琳上次喝水已经过去了24个多小时，
eaten or used the bathroom. The man guided her to a plastic chair with a bed pan under it, the type he used in hospitals. When she finished using it, Colleen asked, when will I get to go home? Yet again he replied, soon. Colleen's gag was removed as she was offered her first meal since her ordeal began, a plate of cooked potatoes and a glass of water. After she ate, she was strapped back up to the ceiling and to left to dangle. Colline accepted there was no use trying to fight and instead focused on
吃东西或上厕所。男人引导她坐到一把下面放着便盆的塑料椅子上，那是他在医院用的那种。当她用完后，科琳问：“我什么时候能回家？”他再次回答说：“很快。”科琳的口塞被取下，她得到了自磨难开始以来的第一顿饭：一盘煮土豆和一杯水。吃完后，她又被绑回天花板上悬挂着。科琳接受了反抗无用的事实，转而专注于
enduring the pain. After a short while, she was let down and made to lie on the rack while wearing the head box. She was left in complete isolation. Twenty-three excruciating hours passed. Moaning from pain and discomfort, Colleen finally felt the head box unlatch. It was the woman this time. I'm cold," Colleen said. The woman laid a blanket over her naked body. Colleen was baffled by this act of kindness, but eventually fell asleep. She was later woken by the man who released her and took her to the bedpan.
忍受痛苦。过了一会儿，她被放下来，戴着头罩躺在刑架上。她被完全隔离了。二十三个痛苦难熬的小时过去了。科琳因疼痛和不适而呻吟，终于感觉到头罩被解开了。这次是那个女人。科琳说：“我很冷。”女人给她的裸体盖上了一条毯子。科琳对这种善举感到困惑，但最终还是睡着了。后来她被男人叫醒，他解开她并带她去用便盆。
He then offered her two egg-sullied sandwiches and a glass of water. Colleen was desperately thirsty after spending the day in the stuffy head box, but had lost her appetite entirely. She thanked the man while telling him, I'm not very hungry. Angard, he snatched the sandwiches away and scolded Colleen for being ungrateful. He strapped her back up to the ceiling with all of the gags and restraints in place, then whipped Colleen in what felt like an act of vengeance. Eventually she passed out from the unbearable pain. When she regained consciousness, the icebox was pushed underneath her.
他随后给了她两个沾着蛋液的三明治和一杯水。科琳在闷热的头罩里待了一天后感到极度口渴，但已经完全失去了食欲。她感谢了男人，并告诉他：“我不怎么饿。”他很生气，一把抢走三明治，责骂科琳不知好歹。他把她重新绑回天花板上，戴上所有的口塞和束缚，然后鞭打科琳，这感觉像是一种报复行为。最终，她因无法忍受的剧痛而昏了过去。当她恢复意识时，冰柜被推到了她身下。
Colleen didn't have the strength to pull herself onto it, and the mere effort caused her to black out again. When she came to this time, the icebox was gone. She began yelling for help and begging for mercy. The man told her to shut up and relax, reiterating that it would be over soon. After another torture session, he asked sarcastically, Now are you going to eat your sandwich? Colleen forced the food down, then she was locked to the rack with the head box on. Colleen determined there was just one key to survival.
科琳没有力气爬上去，仅仅是这个动作就让她再次昏厥。当她这次醒来时，冰柜不见了。她开始大声呼救并乞求怜悯。男人叫她闭嘴并放松，重申一切很快就会结束。在又一轮折磨后，他讽刺地问：“现在你愿意吃你的三明治了吗？”科琳强迫自己咽下食物，然后她被锁在刑架上，戴着头罩。科琳认定生存只有一个关键。
Obey. Colleen soon found herself in an ongoing routine. For 23 hours a day, she was chained naked to the rack while wearing the head box. In the remaining hour, she was released to use the bed pan, drink a glass of water, and eat a basic meal, which was usually a sandwich or leftovers. Then she was forced to endure another round
服从。科琳很快发现自己陷入了一种持续的日常。每天23个小时，她赤身裸体地被锁在刑架上，戴着头罩。在剩下的一个小时里，她被释放去使用便盆、喝一杯水，并吃一顿简单的饭菜，通常是三明治或剩菜。然后她被迫忍受另一轮
of sadistic punishment, which her captor would photograph. Days into Colleen's captivity, the woman came down to the basement again. She told Colleen, I want you to know you were here to take the pain for me, but don't worry, there won't be any sex. She asked Colleen what she would do if she was released. With a hint of sarcasm, Colleen replied,
施虐惩罚，她的绑架者会拍下这些过程。在科琳被囚禁几天后，那个女人又来到了地下室。她告诉科琳：“我想让你知道，你在这里是为了替我承受痛苦，但别担心，不会有性行为。”她问科琳如果被释放会做什么。科琳带着一丝讽刺回答说：
I'd go to the police and tell them I'd been kidnapped. Stupid said the woman. She then latched the head box shut again, leaving Colleen to agonize over the thought that she'd just missed a chance to escape by not choosing her answer more carefully. A week into her captivity, Colleen heard the sound of someone soaring wood and hammering nails in the basement.
“我会去警察局告诉他们我被绑架了。”女人说：“蠢货。”然后她再次锁上头罩，留下科琳为自己刚才没能更谨慎地回答而错失逃跑机会感到痛苦。在被囚禁一周后，科琳听到地下室里有人锯木头和钉钉子的声音。
The noise filled her with anxiety, as she knew whatever was being built was likely something to enhance her misery. Days later, Colleen ate her one and only meal before a single chain was wrapped around her neck and secured with a large padlock. The remainder of the chain went down the length of her body and was secured around her ankles with a second padlock. Step in, the man commanded. Colleen was forced into another box, this one, coffin-like in design and shape.
噪音让她充满焦虑，因为她知道建造的东西很可能是为了增加她的痛苦。几天后，科琳吃完了她唯一的一顿饭，然后一根铁链绕在她的脖子上，并用一把大挂锁锁住。铁链的其余部分顺着她的身体向下，并用第二把挂锁锁在她的脚踝上。男人命令道：“走进去。”科琳被迫进入另一个箱子，这个箱子在设计和形状上像棺材一样。
It was made of particle board which itched and left splinters in Colleen's skin. The box was fitted into a second larger box which provided additional soundproofing. Colleen no longer had to wear the carpet at head box all the time, but the effect was the same. She was ordered to lie down before a lid was placed on top and padlocked a shard, completely sealing her inside. The man had the foresight to include an air hole, but this only filtered in the basement's sickly, moldy odor. Colleen's life returned to the same miserable routine, day-long stretches of isolation only to be released for whipping. Her captors' weapons of choice varied from single long
它由刨花板制成，让科琳的皮肤发痒并扎进木刺。这个箱子被装进第二个更大的箱子里，提供了额外的隔音效果。科琳不再需要一直戴着那个地毯做的头罩，但效果是一样的。她被命令躺下，然后盖上盖子并锁上挂锁，将她完全密封在里面。男人有先见之明地留了一个气孔，但这只会过滤进地下室那股令人作呕的霉味。科琳的生活回到了同样悲惨的日常，整天的隔离，只有在被鞭打时才会被放出来。绑架者选择的武器多种多样，从单根长
pieces of leather to whips with multiple strips that struck her all over with a single blow. Based on the warm temperature throughout the day, Colleen concluded that the man visited her in the early evening when it was cooler. She had no way of keeping track of the days and soon lost count altogether. As the temperature started to drop, Colleen figured summer had given way to water. It had been spring when she left Oregon. She had been imprisoned for months. Escape seemed impossible. Colleen was kept a blindfolded and gagged at all times. The brief hour with her captor was the only time she was moved between restraints, but he was ten inches taller, full of rage, and not someone Colleen could easily fight in
皮条到多条带子的鞭子，一击就能打遍她全身。根据全天温暖的气温，科琳推断男人是在傍晚凉快时来看她的。她无法记录日期，很快就完全记不清了。随着气温开始下降，科琳认为夏天已经让位给秋天了。她离开俄勒冈时还是春天。她已经被囚禁了几个月。逃跑似乎是不可能的。科琳一直被蒙着眼、塞着口。与绑架者相处的短暂一小时是她唯一能在束缚之间移动的时间，但他比她高十英寸，充满愤怒，不是科琳在虚弱状态下能轻易反抗的人。
her weakened state. Even if she managed to get to the basement door, she knew what was likely locked. On the off chance that it was open, she still had no idea where she was. What if she was in the middle of nowhere with no one else around for miles? What if there was a vicious dog or a tall fence she couldn't climb? The thought of giving up crossed the Colleen's mind many times, but she didn't have the means. She maintained hope, but lived in constant fear that at any moment she could be killed by her captor.
即使她设法到达地下室门口，她也知道门很可能是锁着的。万一门开了，她仍然不知道自己在哪里。如果她身处荒郊野外，方圆几英里内空无一人怎么办？如果有一条凶猛的狗或一堵她爬不过去的高墙怎么办？放弃的念头在科琳脑海中闪过多次，但她没有办法。她保持着希望，但生活在随时可能被绑架者杀死的恐惧中。
With little else to do, she focused on survival. Understanding her captor might be the key. She contemplated his motives and wondered what strategies she could use to keep him calm. Most importantly, how could she make him see her as a person? Over time, Colleen adapted her behavior to control her circumstances as best she could. She learnt that begging, pleading, crying, fighting or struggling only aroused her captor and fueled his sadistic rage. This in turn prolonged her torture. So Colleen trained herself to suppress all physical and emotional reactions. This dissipated her captors' desire as he had no fun beating a limp
由于没什么别的事可做，她专注于生存。了解她的绑架者可能是关键。她思考他的动机，想知道可以用什么策略让他保持冷静。最重要的是，她怎样才能让他把她看作一个人？随着时间的推移，科琳调整了自己的行为，尽可能地控制自己的处境。她了解到，乞求、恳求、哭泣、反抗或挣扎只会激起绑架者的兴趣，助长他的施虐狂怒。这反过来又延长了她的折磨。因此，科琳训练自己压抑所有的身体和情感反应。这消散了绑架者的欲望，因为他觉得殴打一个瘫软的
body. Preventing him from seeing her as weak and vulnerable also gave Colleen a sense of power. The only time she permitted herself to cry was when she was alone in the box. The men rarely spoke except to bark orders like stand up, give me your wrists or turn around. Colleen learned the hard way that she had to keep quiet too. Once when she desperately needed to use the bedpan, Colleen rattled her chains and yelled for attention. The men rushed down into the basement, pulled Colleen out of the box and immediately strung her up the ceiling. He violently whipped her back and remarked, this is for making so much noise.
身体毫无乐趣。防止他把自己看作软弱和脆弱的人也给了科琳一种力量感。她唯一允许自己哭泣的时候是独自在箱子里的时候。男人很少说话，除了吼出“站起来”、“把手腕给我”或“转过去”这样的命令。科琳吃尽苦头才明白，她也必须保持安静。有一次，当她急需使用便盆时，科琳摇晃锁链并大声呼救。男人冲进地下室，把科琳从箱子里拉出来，立即把她吊在天花板上。他猛烈地鞭打她的背部，并说：“这是因为你制造了太多噪音。”
From then on, she stayed silent. Colleen's captor was inspired by images of bondage he found in pornographic magazines. He used Colleen as a model to copy the ones he liked, constantly moving her between the box, the rack, and hanging her from the ceiling. Sometimes Colleen would be hung upside down by the ankles. Other times she was choked until she blacked out. The smaller head box was applied often. During one particularly harrowing ordeal, Colleen soiled herself. Furious, the man rubbed Colleen's nose in her own waist.
从那以后，她保持沉默。科琳的绑架者受到他在色情杂志上看到的束缚图片的启发。他把科琳当作模特来模仿他喜欢的那些姿势，不断地让她在箱子、刑架和吊在天花板之间转换。有时科琳会被脚踝倒吊起来。有时她会被掐到昏厥。那个较小的头罩经常被使用。在一次特别痛苦的折磨中，科琳失禁了。男人大发雷霆，把科琳的鼻子按在她的排泄物里。
Sometimes, when Colleen was lying in the box, she could hear the men and women having sex on top of her. Every once in a while, Colleen's captors provided her with an unexpected gift. The woman once brought her a cold glass of lemonade, and she was occasionally fed something special, like pancakes, French toast, or jelly. Months into her captivity, Colleen was finally given a toothbrush to clean her teeth. These random acts of kindness were rare and done without explanation. Colleen placated the couple in the hopes of increasing her privileges, yet she never found a way to diminish or prevent the assault.
有时，当科琳躺在箱子里时，她能听到男人和女人在她上面发生性关系。偶尔，科琳的绑架者会给她一份意想不到的礼物。女人曾经给她带来一杯冰柠檬水，她偶尔也会吃到一些特别的东西，比如煎饼、法式吐司或果冻。被囚禁几个月后，科琳终于得到了一把牙刷来清洁牙齿。这些随机的善举很少见，而且没有任何解释。科琳安抚这对夫妇，希望能增加她的特权，但她从未找到减少或阻止袭击的方法。
The stress took a toll on Colleen's body and she stopped menstruating. Then, one day, while she was in the box, her period suddenly returned. Colleen's capt captain was furious. He handcuffed her and led her up the basement stairs into a bathroom. To Colleen's surprise, for the first time since her ordeal began, she was permitted to take a bath. Her blindfold and gags were kept in place, but her handcuffs were removed so she could wash herself. The woman attempted to brush, wash, and condition Colleen's mattered and filthy hair, but nothing could untangle the knots, not even cooking oil. Eventually, the woman took a pair of scissors and hacked Colleen's beloved waist-length
压力对科琳的身体造成了损害，她停止了月经。然后有一天，当她在箱子里时，她的月经突然恢复了。科琳的绑架者非常愤怒。他给她戴上手铐，带她走上地下室的楼梯进入浴室。令科琳惊讶的是，自磨难开始以来，她第一次被允许洗澡。她的眼罩和口塞保持原样，但手铐被解开了，以便她可以清洗自己。女人试图梳理、清洗和护理科琳纠结且肮脏的头发，但什么也解不开那些结，连食用油都不行。最终，女人拿出一把剪刀，剪掉了科琳心爱的齐腰
locks to shoulder hide. The mutilation left Colleen broken-hearted. After her bath, Colleen's hands and feet were hogtied behind her back. For two hours her head was dunked in and out of the water. Whenever Colleen felt on the brink of death, the man would pull her out by the hair so she could grab one desperate breath before her head was submerged again. All the while Colleen saw the familiar flash of a camera. With her lungs burning Colleen was eventually taken back into the basement, secured face down on the rack and assaulted. Colleen was then sealed in the box for another day.
长发，剪到了肩膀高度。这种毁容让科琳心碎。洗完澡后，科琳的手脚被反绑在身后。两个小时里，她的头被反复按进水里又提出来。每当科琳感到濒临死亡时，男人就会抓住她的头发把她拉出来，让她在头再次被淹没前绝望地吸一口气。整个过程中，科琳看到了熟悉的相机闪光灯。肺部灼痛的科琳最终被带回地下室，面朝下固定在刑架上并遭到袭击。随后，科琳被关进箱子里又过了一天。
Colleen thought about all the small everyday freedoms that others were taking for granted. Breakfast, clothes, shopping, television. She kept her mind busy by reflecting on fond memories, planning Thanksgiving dinners for when she was reunited with her family, and fantasizing about a future with a beautiful home and a child of her own. But her thoughts could only stretch so far and eventually she reached a mental blank. Time slowed with every minute feeling like an hour as days slipped away. When Colleen finally drifted off to sleep, she was plagued by nightmares. When awake, Colleen was gripped by loneliness.
科琳想到了其他人认为理所当然的所有日常小自由。早餐、衣服、购物、电视。她通过回忆美好的记忆来充实自己的大脑，计划着与家人团聚时的感恩节晚餐，并幻想拥有一个美丽的家和自己的孩子的未来。但她的思绪只能延伸到这里，最终她陷入了精神空白。时间变慢了，每一分钟都感觉像一个小时，日子一天天溜走。当科琳终于昏昏沉沉地睡去时，她被噩梦困扰。清醒时，科琳被孤独感紧紧抓住。
She tried to fill the void by speaking to God. Colleen's childhood had involved going to church, though she wasn't strongly religious. But now Colleen felt God was the only one who could hear her. Prayer somewhat lessened the feeling of isolation and allowed Colleen to feel connected to her loved ones, whom she knew would be praying for her. It also provided positive affirmations in the midst of her nightmares. Colleen once had a vision that her box was opened by angels, who reassured her that everything would be all right. In another, Colleen shared some regrets with her deceased grandfather, who stroked her hair and said,
她试图通过与上帝交谈来填补空白。科琳的童年去过教堂，尽管她并不虔诚。但现在科琳觉得上帝是唯一能听到她声音的人。祈祷在一定程度上减轻了孤独感，让科琳感到与她所爱的人有了联系，她知道他们会为她祈祷。它还在噩梦中提供了积极的心理暗示。科琳曾经有一个幻觉，她的箱子被天使打开了，他们安慰她说一切都会好起来的。在另一个幻觉中，科琳与她已故的祖父分享了一些遗憾，他抚摸着她的头发说：
it's all right, Colleen. These visions provided her with the warmth and security she was longing for. Months continued to pass, with Colleen still restrained and blindfolded. She was unable to scratch herself or stretch her aching limbs. The house above the basement felt a hundred miles away, and the world beyond that was like an entirely different planet. Her captors shared no information or news. Coupled with the total sensory deprivation, Colleen was mentally starving.
“没事的，科琳。”这些幻觉提供了她渴望的温暖和安全感。几个月过去了，科琳仍然被束缚和蒙着眼。她无法抓痒或伸展酸痛的四肢。地下室上面的房子感觉像在一百英里之外，而那之外的世界就像一个完全不同的星球。她的绑架者没有分享任何信息或新闻。再加上完全的感官剥夺，科琳在精神上处于饥饿状态。
Yet, once a month, Colleen was allowed to take a bath. She eventually earned the right to bathe alone. Despite this, she still couldn't entertain the thought of escaping. The lack of certainty was just too much. If her attempt failed, what punishment would she have to endure then? The woman had once warned Colleen. If you walk out the back door, you might as well put a shotgun to your head
然而，每个月一次，科琳被允许洗澡。她最终赢得了独自洗澡的权利。尽管如此，她仍然无法产生逃跑的念头。不确定性实在太大了。如果尝试失败了，她还要忍受什么样的惩罚？女人曾经警告过科琳：“如果你从后门走出去，你还不如拿把猎枪对着自己的头，
and pull the trigger. Although death offered an escape, Colleen was overcome by a will to live. The woman rarely spoke to Colleen and mostly stayed out of the basement, but she did occasionally participate in the abuse by biting, whipping and poking Colleen with sharp objects. Colleen once heard the man refer to the woman as Jan. She knew never to reveal this as having such information could prove fatal.
扣动扳机。”虽然死亡提供了一种逃脱方式，但科琳被强烈的求生欲所克服。女人很少和科琳说话，大部分时间都待在地下室外面，但她偶尔会通过咬、鞭打和用尖锐物体戳科琳来参与虐待。科琳曾经听到男人称呼那个女人为简。她知道绝不能透露这一点，因为掌握这样的信息可能是致命的。
Colleen wondered if Jan participated in the abuse because she wanted to, or because the man forced her. The possibility that Jan could also be a victim was yet another unanswered question that occupied her mind. One day, a blindfolded Colleen was ordered to sit on the concrete floor in the center of the basement. Her ankle chains were secured to something to prevent her from moving around. The man then directed Colleen's hands until they came into contact with the piece of wood. He handed her some sandpaper and demanded that she sand the wood all night until its
科琳想知道简参与虐待是因为她想这样做，还是因为男人强迫她。简也可能是一个受害者的可能性是另一个占据她脑海的未解之谜。一天，蒙着眼的科琳被命令坐在地下室中央的水泥地上。她的脚踝锁链被固定在某处，以防止她四处走动。男人随后引导科琳的手，直到它们接触到一块木头。他递给她一些砂纸，并要求她整晚打磨那块木头，直到它
surface was smooth. Any questions, he asked. She shook her head. A new box was then latched onto Colleen's head. This one was at least 10 pounds heavier than the previous one, and Colleen couldn't hold her head up. The man had anticipated this. He'd rectified it by attaching strings to the box, which were then looped over a pipe on the ceiling and connected to several containers of water that hung as a counterbalance. Although awkward and unpleasant, it enabled Colleen to get the project done over several nights.
表面很光滑。他问，有什么问题吗？她摇了摇头。随后，一个新盒子被锁在了科琳的头上。这个盒子至少比之前那个重10磅，科琳根本抬不起头。那个男人预料到了这一点。他通过在盒子上系上绳子，将绳子绕过天花板上的管道，并连接到几个作为配重悬挂的水桶上来解决这个问题。虽然笨拙且令人不适，但这使科琳能够在几个晚上内完成项目。
Later, as she lay in the coffin-like box, Colleen heard some construction work taking place in the basement. It continued every night for several weeks, leaving Colleen to wonder what fresh horrors laid in store. One night, the man led Colleen to his new creation, a small concrete room under the timber stairs lit by a single light bulb. There, he restrained Colleen to a chair, then he left. From behind the door, the man instructed Colleen to remove her blindfold. It was the first time she'd taken it off in six months, blinding white light immediately burned her eyes. As her vision adjusted, she saw a burlap sack full of walnuts lying at her feet.
后来，当她躺在棺材般的盒子里时，科琳听到地下室里传来一些施工的声音。这种情况持续了几个星期，每天晚上都有，让科琳不禁猜测还有什么新的恐怖在等着她。一天晚上，男人把科琳带到了他的新作品——一个位于木楼梯下方的混凝土小房间，里面只亮着一个灯泡。在那里，他把科琳绑在椅子上，然后离开了。门外，男人指示科琳摘下眼罩。这是她六个月来第一次摘下眼罩，刺眼的白光立刻灼伤了她的眼睛。当她的视力适应后，她看到脚边放着一袋核桃。
The man said, When I come back tomorrow morning, I expect each walnut to be showed and placed in the empty bowl. From that point on, a new routine emerged. Colleen still spent her days trapped in the box and was released in the evenings to eat, use the bed pan and endure yet another torture session. But she was then locked overnight in the makeshift workshop to complete an array of tasks, from shelling nuts to crochet and macrame projects. Each morning, before being returned to the box, she was ordered to reapply her blindfold so she
男人说，明天早上我回来时，我希望每个核桃都被剥好并放在空碗里。从那时起，一种新的日常安排出现了。科琳白天仍然被困在盒子里，晚上被放出来吃饭、使用便盆并忍受又一轮的折磨。但她随后会被锁在临时工作室里过夜，完成一系列任务，从剥核桃到钩针编织和花边工艺品。每天早上，在被送回盒子之前，她都被命令重新戴上眼罩，这样她
wouldn't see her captors face. Colleen ascertained that she was making items for her captors to sell. Although still miserable, she was grateful to have something to keep her occupied. But this new routine wasn't always guaranteed. Sometimes the man would leave Colleen in the workshop all day without explanation. Other times she'd be left in the box overnight without being put to work at all. It was as though her captors were intentionally making her life unpredictable to reinforce their control.
就不会看到绑架者的脸。科琳断定她是在为绑架者制作商品出售。虽然仍然很痛苦，但她很庆幸有事情可以做。但这种新的日常安排并不总是能保证。有时男人会把科琳整天留在工作室里，没有任何解释。其他时候，她会被留在盒子里过夜，根本不用干活。就好像她的绑架者在故意让她的生活变得不可预测，以加强他们的控制。
The onset of winter marked the seventh month of Colleen's captivity, although she still had no concept of the date or time. She'd lost a significant amount of weight, and as she remained completely naked, the cold was unbearable. In one of their rare acts of compassion, her captors gave her a jacket and night-gown, the first items of clothing Colleen had worn since entering the basement. A further drop in temperature indicated Christmas was approaching, but the day itself came and went without anything to mark the occasion.
冬天的到来标志着科琳被囚禁的第七个月，尽管她仍然对日期或时间没有任何概念。她体重减轻了很多，而且由于她一直完全赤身裸体，寒冷令人难以忍受。在他们罕见的同情行为中，绑架者给了她一件夹克和睡袍，这是科琳进入地下室以来穿的第一件衣服。气温的进一步下降表明圣诞节即将来临，但这一天在没有任何庆祝活动的情况下就过去了。
The same went for Colleen's 21st birthday which fell on December 31, and then New Year's Day. As 1978 commenced, the isolation Colleen felt was profound. But on Wednesday, January 25, something unexpected happened. Colleen was in the workshop busy with her latest project when suddenly the particle board door swung open. With no warning to put her blindfold back on, Colleen saw her captors for the first time since the day of her abduction.
科琳12月31日的21岁生日以及元旦也是如此。随着1978年的开始，科琳感到的孤独感是深刻的。但在1月25日星期三，发生了一些意想不到的事情。科琳正在工作室忙于她的最新项目，突然刨花板门打开了。没有预先警告让她戴回眼罩，科琳自被绑架那天起第一次见到了她的绑架者。
When she locked eyes with the man, she felt it was like looking into the eyes of the devil. A smirk appeared on his face as Jan stood behind him. Colleen was frozen in shock and fear. The couple handed Colleen a piece of paper and a pen and told her to practice writing her name. Unshore where this was leading, Colleen did as she was told.
当她与那个男人对视时，她觉得就像是在注视着魔鬼的眼睛。当简站在他身后时，他的脸上露出了冷笑。科琳因震惊和恐惧而僵住了。这对夫妇递给科琳一张纸和一支笔，告诉她练习写自己的名字。科琳不知道这会导致什么，但还是照做了。
As she repeatedly began scrolling the words, Colleen stand. The man told her, they know you're here. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Too busy achieving all your day-to-day goals to cook, but want to make sure you're reading well? With Factor, skip the extra trip to the grocery store and the chopping, prepping and cleaning up too,
当她开始反复书写这些字时，科琳站着。男人告诉她，他们知道你在这里。Casefile很快就会回来。感谢您通过收听本节目的赞助商来支持我们。忙于实现所有日常目标而没时间做饭，但又想确保自己吃得好？有了Factor，省去了去杂货店的额外行程，也省去了切菜、准备和清理的时间，
while still getting the flavor and nutritional quality you need. Factors fresh, never frozen meals are ready in just 2 minutes, so all you have to do is heat and enjoy, then get back to crushing your goals. Factors is America's number 1 ready toat milk kit, and with meals delivered straight to your door, you'll save time, eat well, and stay on track with your healthy lifestyle. Choose from over 34 weekly flavor pack to dietician-approved meals and level up with gourmet plus options, prepared to perfection by chefs and ready to eat in record time. Treat yourself to upscale meals with premium ingredients like
同时还能获得所需的风味和营养质量。Factor新鲜、从不冷冻的餐点只需2分钟即可准备好，所以您所要做的就是加热并享用，然后继续为实现目标而努力。Factor是美国排名第一的预制餐包，餐点直接送到您家门口，您将节省时间、吃得好，并保持健康的饮食习惯。从超过34种每周风味包装的营养师认可餐点中进行选择，并通过由厨师精心准备、可在创纪录时间内食用的美食升级选项来提升您的体验。用优质食材犒劳自己，例如
broccoli, leeks, truffle butter and asparagus. Case file team member, Rotavia, tells me that factor meals are like something you'd expect to eat at a fancy restaurant. Her favorite is the vegetarian green chili tostada bake with corn salsa and a sour cream, but she also loves the fruit smoothies for a quick on the go meal. Head to factameals.com slash case file 50 and use code case file 50 to get 50% off. That's code case file 50 at factameals. slash CaseFile50 to get 50% off.
西兰花、韭菜、松露黄油和芦笋。Casefile团队成员Rotavia告诉我，Factor的餐点就像您在高级餐厅吃到的东西一样。她最喜欢的是带有玉米莎莎酱和酸奶油的素食青辣椒烤饼，但她也喜欢水果冰沙，作为快速外带的餐点。前往factameals.com/casefile50并使用代码casefile50可获得50%的折扣。即代码casefile50，网址factameals.com/casefile50，可获得50%的折扣。
When two friends go missing back-to-back and in between their disappearances, a third friend is murdered, their mothers are the first to find connections between the three cases. Along with a local crime reporter, they begin an investigation that unearthed heartbreaking revelations, which no one was prepared for. This is the story behind the Bakersfield 3, the latest original podcast from Case File Presents. This series is the culmination of five years of reporting, research and interviews by award-winning journalist Olivia LaVois. The Bakersfield 3 features exclusive interviews with key players as crucial events unfolded.
当两个朋友接连失踪，而在她们失踪期间，第三个朋友被谋杀时，她们的母亲是第一批发现这三起案件之间联系的人。在一位当地犯罪记者的帮助下，她们开始了一项调查，揭开了令人心碎的真相，而没有人对此做好准备。这就是“贝克斯菲尔德3人组”背后的故事，这是Casefile Presents的最新原创播客。该系列是屡获殊荣的记者奥利维亚·拉沃伊斯（Olivia LaVois）五年报道、研究和采访的结晶。“贝克斯菲尔德3人组”以关键人物的独家采访为特色，展现了关键事件的展开过程。
Listeners will also hear audio from police interrogations, jailhouse phone calls, an explosive trial, and more. This is like no story you've ever heard before. The entire Bakersfield 3 series is available now. Listen to all 15 episodes of the Bakersfield 3 wherever you get your podcasts. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. Colleen's mind raised as a glimmer of hope ignited within.
听众还将听到来自警方审讯、监狱电话、爆炸性审判等的音频。这就像你以前从未听过的任何故事。整个“贝克斯菲尔德3人组”系列现已推出。无论您在哪里收听播客，都可以收听“贝克斯菲尔德3人组”的所有15集。感谢您收听本节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供优质内容。科琳的心跳加速，心中燃起了一丝希望。
Who were they? The police, her family? The man then said that someone from the company was waiting upstairs, adding, we can't keep the man waiting. Colleen's hope was promptly extinguished. Her captor explained that the company had discovered Colleen was being held captive. The couple were being forced to pay a $1,600 fee and had to register Colleen immediately to make her legal.
他们是谁？警察，她的家人？男人随后说，公司里有人在楼上等着，并补充说，我们不能让那个人久等。科琳的希望很快破灭了。她的绑架者解释说，公司已经发现科琳被囚禁了。这对夫妇被迫支付1600美元的费用，并必须立即登记科琳，使她合法化。
Before Colleen could make any sense of what he was saying, he handed her a copy of a newspaper titled Inside News, which was dated Sunday January 1, 1978. Colleen's attention was drawn to an article with the headline, they sell themselves body and soul when they sign the slave contract. The article began. Just out of sight of the general public, young beautiful women are being abducted and sold into slavery in San Francisco to wealthy and powerful men. The company, a vast underground syndicate, administers the contracts and controls the market.
在科琳还没弄明白他在说什么之前，他递给她一份名为《内部新闻》的报纸，日期是1978年1月1日星期日。科琳的注意力被一篇标题为“他们签署奴隶合同时出卖了自己的身体和灵魂”的文章所吸引。文章开头写道：在公众视野之外，年轻漂亮的女性在旧金山被绑架并卖给富有的权势男人作为奴隶。公司，一个庞大的地下集团，管理着合同并控制着市场。
According to the article, once the transactions were sealed with the contract, the women legally became the property of the masters who bought them. They were given a slave name and made to permanently wear a collar to identify their position. Any woman who resisted was sent to the company's remedial training facility in San Francisco, a place known as Ranta Dungeon. The company also had headquarters in Sacramento. Colleen began to shake. She never knew such a business existed and couldn't believe what she was reading.
根据文章，一旦交易通过合同密封，这些女性在法律上就成为了购买她们的主人的财产。她们被赋予一个奴隶名字，并被迫永久佩戴项圈以表明她们的身份。任何反抗的女性都会被送往公司在旧金山的补救训练设施，一个被称为“兰塔地牢”的地方。公司在萨克拉门托也有总部。科琳开始颤抖。她从不知道有这样的生意存在，无法相信她所读到的内容。
The article explained how a fair market value was determined for each slave and how the purchasing process worked. It even featured a sample of one of the legally binding slave contracts. Colleen's captor handed her a piece of paper which he ordered her to read and sign. Then he reiterated, We can't keep the company man waiting. Typewritten on a high quality piece of paper with an ornate heading printed at the top and an official looking seal at the bottom, the contract opened with the words.
文章解释了如何为每个奴隶确定公平的市场价值，以及购买过程是如何运作的。它甚至还刊登了一份具有法律约束力的奴隶合同样本。科琳的绑架者递给她一张纸，命令她阅读并签字。然后他重申，我们不能让公司的人久等。合同打印在一张高质量的纸上，顶部印有华丽的标题，底部有看起来很正式的印章，合同以这些话开头。
This indenture made the 25th day of January in the year of our Lord 1,978, between Colleen Stan, hereafter known as Slave, and Michael Powers, hereafter known as Slave and Michael Powers, hereafter known as Master. It continued by detailing how Colleen, referred to as Slave, would humbly submit the entirety of herself to her Master. Her body, her will and her soul would all belong to him. There were four specific points that Colleen had to promise to, quote, 1. She shall immediately, diligently and enthusiastically comply with and submit her full
本契约订立于主后1978年1月25日，在科琳·斯坦（以下称为奴隶）与迈克尔·鲍尔斯（以下称为主人）之间。它继续详细说明了科琳（被称为奴隶）将如何谦卑地将她的全部身心提交给她的主人。她的身体、她的意志和她的灵魂都将属于他。科琳必须承诺遵守四点具体要求，引用如下：1. 她应立即、勤奋且热情地遵守并服从她的全部
being to any and all directions or desires of Master or his assigns, which he or they may express by word, signal, action, or any other means. 2. She shall at all times afford Master absolute respect. She'll address him only as Sir or Master. She'll station herself in a physical position subordinate to his whenever possible, and she'll speak to or otherwise distract him only when granted his permission. 3. She shall constantly maintain her female body parts in such circumstances as will demonstrate and ensure that they are fully open to him. In particular, she shall never cross her legs
身心，服从主人或其受让人通过言语、信号、行动或任何其他方式表达的任何及所有指示或愿望。2. 她应始终给予主人绝对的尊重。她只能称呼他为“先生”或“主人”。她应尽可能将自己置于从属于他的身体位置，并且只有在获得他的许可时才能与他交谈或以其他方式分散他的注意力。3. 她应始终保持其女性身体部位处于能够展示并确保它们对他完全开放的状态。特别是，她绝不能交叉双腿
in his presence, shall wear no undergarments at any time and shall cover no part of her body with a parallel or material of any description except when the act of doing so and design of the item are expressly approved by him. 4. She shall preserve her female body parts for the exclusive use of him and his assigns, which use shall be the sole source of his pleasures, and she shall engage in no self-gradification or any physical contact with any other. The contract noted that Colleen had become sullied by her interactions with others prior to
在他的面前，任何时候都不得穿内衣，并且不得用任何描述的布料或材料覆盖她身体的任何部分，除非这样做和物品的设计得到他的明确批准。4. 她应为他及其受让人的独家使用保留其女性身体部位，该使用应是他快乐的唯一来源，并且她不得进行任何自我满足或与任何其他人进行任何身体接触。合同指出，科琳在进入主人的占有之前，因与他人的互动而变得不洁。
coming into her master's possession. She was required to confess to this and request that the master free her from any bad habits via quote, retraining with corporal punishment. The contract concluded with the words, In witness whereof, Slave has here and two set her hand, and Master has designed to seal these presents by permanently if fixing his collar about her neck on the date first above written. Signed by Slave, whose collar was sealed and who was delivered onto Master on the date above mentioned in the presence of. Forever slave Colleen Stan, master Michael Powers, witness Janet Powers.
她被要求承认这一点，并请求主人通过引用“体罚再训练”来使她摆脱任何坏习惯。合同以这些话结束：作为见证，奴隶已在此签字，主人已决定通过在上述日期将他的项圈永久固定在她的脖子上以密封这些礼物。由奴隶签署，其项圈已密封并于上述日期在以下人员在场的情况下交付给主人。永远的奴隶科琳·斯坦，主人迈克尔·鲍尔斯，见证人珍妮特·鲍尔斯。
Colleen burst into tears. She could no longer maintain her stoicism, exclaiming, this is the work of Satan. Michael angrily demanded that Colleen just sign the contract. She asked, What if I don't? Through gridded teeth he responded, I will make you wish you had. Colleen tried to calm down, but she explained that she couldn't sign away her soul
科琳泪流满面。她再也无法保持冷静，惊呼道：这是撒旦的杰作。迈克尔愤怒地要求科琳签字。她问，如果我不签呢？他咬牙切齿地回答：我会让你后悔没签。科琳试图冷静下来，但她解释说她不能出卖她的灵魂，
as that belonged to God. All right, Michael agreed. Now sign. Next to the words forever slave, Colleen stands shakily tried to distort her signature in a desperate attempt to make it clear she'd been forced to sign against her will. Both Michael and Janet then signed the document. While Janet took the contract upstairs, Michael told Colleen, Let me tell you about my wife.
因为它属于上帝。好吧，迈克尔同意了。现在签字。在“永远的奴隶”字样旁边，科琳·斯坦颤抖着试图扭曲她的签名，绝望地试图表明她是违背意愿被迫签字的。迈克尔和珍妮特随后都在文件上签了字。当珍妮特把合同拿到楼上时，迈克尔告诉科琳：让我告诉你关于我妻子的事。
He explained that Janet was once a slave too. She'd escaped her previous owner and flagged down a police officer, not realizing that he too was a member of the company. She was taken to renter dungeon for remedial training, where she was brutally punished as an example to other slaves. A cross was then placed around her neck. This signified that for $10,000, Janet could be purchased for the purpose of being tortured to death.
他解释说，珍妮特曾经也是一个奴隶。她逃离了以前的主人并拦住了一名警察，却没意识到他也是公司的成员。她被带到“兰塔地牢”接受补救训练，在那里她受到了残酷的惩罚，作为对其他奴隶的警示。然后，一个十字架被戴在她的脖子上。这标志着，只要支付10,000美元，就可以购买珍妮特，目的是将她折磨致死。
Michael explained that over the years he earned thousands of dollars of credit by helping the company track down runaway slaves. When he saw Janet's cross, he felt sorry for her. He used his credit to buy Janet and take her home. Michael told Colleen that the company was a secret organization run by powerful men who enslaved, trained, transported and sold women. While the group was completely unknown to the average citizen, it had grown into a powerful, influential and financial empire. Members were powerful and wealthy individuals, including politicians, judges, doctors, and
迈克尔解释说，多年来，他通过帮助公司追踪逃跑的奴隶赚取了数千美元的信用点。当他看到珍妮特的十字架时，他为她感到难过。他用他的信用点买下了珍妮特并带她回家。迈克尔告诉科琳，公司是一个由权势男人经营的秘密组织，他们奴役、训练、运输和贩卖女性。虽然这个组织对普通公民来说完全陌生，但它已经发展成为一个强大、有影响力且财力雄厚的帝国。成员都是有权有势的富人，包括政客、法官、医生和
members of law enforcement. Michael explained that for an annual fee of $1600, the company provided him with 24-hour home security, including monitoring his house and telephone line. If Colleen tried to escape, the company would stop at nothing to find her, even harming her family if they had to. Colleen would then spend five days being violently punished by the company. If she survived, she'd be resold to the highest bidder. Michael already knew of at least one dangerous man who was eager to buy a Colleen. Colleen was told that her contract was permanent and unbreakable.
执法人员。迈克尔解释说，每年支付1600美元，公司就为他提供24小时的家庭安全保障，包括监控他的房子和电话线。如果科琳试图逃跑，公司会不惜一切代价找到她，甚至在必要时伤害她的家人。科琳随后将花费五天时间受到公司的暴力惩罚。如果她活下来，她将被转卖给出价最高的人。迈克尔已经知道至少有一个危险的男人渴望买下科琳。科琳被告知她的合同是永久且不可打破的。
Every so often her obedience would be tested with a special punishment. According to Michael, he had no control over the company's demands. All he knew was that Colleen would remain his slave for life. Michael laid out the new rules for Colleen. As he slave, she must address him as master or sir, and his wife as men. She must only speak when spoken to or when absolutely necessary. When doing so, she had to kneel down, keep her arms at her sides and her eyes focused on the floor. Colleen was forbidden from crossing her legs or wearing
每隔一段时间，她的服从性就会受到特殊惩罚的考验。据迈克尔说，他无法控制公司的要求。他所知道的只是科琳将终身为他的奴隶。迈克尔为科琳制定了新规则。作为他的奴隶，她必须称呼他为“主人”或“先生”，称呼他的妻子为“夫人”。她只能在被问到或绝对必要时说话。这样做时，她必须跪下，双臂放在身体两侧，眼睛盯着地板。科琳被禁止交叉双腿或穿
clothing unless permitted to do so. Michael told her, The girl previously known as Colleen Stan is gone. Colleen would henceforth be known by her slave name, Kay. A metal collar adorned with a gold leaf was locked around her knack. Michael asked Colleen if she understood. Colleen replied, yes, Master. Weeks later, Colleen was handed eliminated card featuring the company's official seal. This was proof of her official registration as a slave for life, and was put on display above the workshop door. Michael continued filling Colleen's head with horrifying stories about what happened to
衣服，除非得到允许。迈克尔告诉她：以前那个叫科琳·斯坦的女孩已经死了。科琳从此将以她的奴隶名字“凯”为人所知。一个装饰着金叶的金属项圈锁在她的脖子上。迈克尔问科琳是否明白。科琳回答：是的，主人。几周后，科琳收到了一张印有公司官方印章的层压卡片。这是她作为终身奴隶正式登记的证明，并被展示在工作室门上方。迈克尔继续用关于逃跑奴隶遭遇的恐怖故事填满科琳的脑海，
slaves who escaped. One slave's mother was tortured for information. When the slave was eventually found, her arms and legs were surgically removed without anesthesia, her tongue was cut out, and her eyes were soldered shut. She was then hung by the hair from a hook above her master's bed and kept alive until she eventually died after a year of suffering. Another captured slave was put alive into a glass box that was filled with the toxic preservative for Mouter Hyde.
那些奴隶的下场。一个奴隶的母亲被折磨以获取信息。当那个奴隶最终被找到时，她的手臂和腿在没有麻醉的情况下被手术切除，她的舌头被割掉，眼睛被焊死。然后她被头发吊在主人床上的钩子上，一直活着，直到一年后在痛苦中死去。另一个被捕的奴隶被活着放进了一个装满有毒防腐剂甲醛的玻璃盒子里。
This gradually turned her remains into what Michael described as a human pickle. Her body, along with those of other slaves who tried to escape, were on display in the company's museum. Colleen struggled to comprehend what she was hearing. Perhaps in any other circumstances, she would have been skeptical of Michael's assertions. But after enduring months of being physically, emotionally, mentally, and spiritually degraded, Colleen was incredibly vulnerable. Although her mind lingered with doubt,
这逐渐将她的遗体变成了迈克尔所说的“人体腌菜”。她的尸体，连同其他试图逃跑的奴隶的尸体，都被陈列在公司的博物馆里。科琳努力理解她所听到的一切。也许在任何其他情况下，她都会对迈克尔的断言持怀疑态度。但在经历了数月身体、情感、精神和灵魂上的贬低后，科琳变得极其脆弱。尽管她的内心仍存疑虑，
she was plagued by nightmares of what could happen to her or her family if the company was indeed real and Colleen crossed them. Michael's stories caused Colleen to fear the company even more than her two captors. Yet, her registration as a slave did lead to one major and welcomed change. For short periods at a time, Colleen was allowed to go upstairs into the house and do chores. Whenever this happened, the doors were kept locked and window shades drawn. Janet didn't wanna make it woman moving around to the house, so Colleen was allowed to wear a night gown. Her blindfold and gag were also removed,
她还是被噩梦所困扰，梦见如果公司真的存在而她又违抗了他们，她或她的家人会遭遇什么。迈克尔的故事让科琳对公司的恐惧甚至超过了对那两个绑架者的恐惧。然而，她作为奴隶的登记确实带来了一个重大的、受欢迎的改变。在短时间内，科琳被允许上楼进屋做家务。每当这时，门都会锁上，窗帘也会拉上。珍妮特不想让别人看到屋里有女人走动，所以科琳被允许穿睡袍。她的眼罩和口塞也被取下，
but she was ordered to keep her eyes casted downward and only speak if spoken to. Once her chores were complete, Colleen had to kneel before her captors and ask, is there anything else you wish for me to do? If not, she was returned to the basement where she was either placed back in her box or ushered into the workshop for more craft projects. Meanwhile, her torture continued. Michael and Janet's house was quaint, but cluttered.
但她被命令必须低着头，除非被问话否则不得开口。家务做完后，科琳必须跪在绑架者面前问：“还有什么需要我做的吗？”如果没有，她就会被送回地下室，要么被关回箱子里，要么被带到工作室做更多的手工项目。与此同时，对她的折磨仍在继续。迈克尔和珍妮特的房子古朴但杂乱。
A kitchen led to a small dining space where an arched doorway then opened to a living room. Whenever Michael yelled at Tension, Colleen had distribute naked and stand under the arch on her tiptoes with her hands stretched toward above her. If Michael was unsatisfied with Colleen's work in any way, she was repeatedly whipped. She had to stay in this position until he called out, at ease. During her lashings, Michael sometimes asked Colleen questions about her past life,
厨房通向一个小餐厅，拱形门洞通往客厅。每当迈克尔对科琳大喊大叫时，她就必须脱光衣服，踮着脚尖站在拱门下，双手向上伸展。如果迈克尔对科琳的工作有任何不满，她就会遭到反复鞭打。她必须保持这个姿势，直到他喊“放松”。在鞭打过程中，迈克尔有时会问科琳关于她过去生活的问题，
such as whether she was a college student. If Colleen answered honestly with yes, she'd be struck again. Further into the house was the bathroom. There was also a small bedroom occupied by her captor's young daughter, who had only been a baby when Colleen was abducted. By the time Colleen saw her again, she was a toddler, walking, but not talking. Inside Michael and Janet's bedroom was a water bed on a large pedestal. In their closet, a wooden panel could be removed from the floor, allowing a direct view into the basement below. Once while she cleaned the house, Colleen came across a letter.
比如她是否是大学生。如果科琳诚实回答“是”，她就会再次遭到殴打。房子深处是浴室。还有一个小卧室，住着绑架者年幼的女儿，科琳被绑架时她还是个婴儿。当科琳再次见到她时，她已经是个蹒跚学步的孩子，会走路但还不会说话。迈克尔和珍妮特的卧室里有一张放在大底座上的水床。在他们的衣柜里，地板上的一块木板可以移开，从而可以直接看到下面的地下室。有一次在打扫房子时，科琳发现了一封信。
It was addressed to Cameron and to Janice Hookah. That was the moment Colleen realized that she'd been misled by her captors with fake names. It also included their address, 1140 Oak Street in Redbluff, California. One February evening, Colleen was let upstairs and onto the couple's water bed. Cameron and Janice lay on either side of her and began kissing. Up until this point, Colleen had injured varying degrees of sexual assault, and Janice lay on either side of her and began kissing. Up until this point, Colleen had injured varying degrees of sexual assault, but had never been forced to have intercourse. That all changed that night.
信是写给卡梅伦和珍妮丝·胡克的。那一刻，科琳意识到她一直被绑架者用假名误导。信中还包括他们的地址，加利福尼亚州雷德布拉夫橡树街1140号。二月的一个晚上，科琳被带到楼上，躺在夫妇俩的水床上。卡梅伦和珍妮丝躺在她两侧开始亲吻。在此之前，科琳已经忍受了不同程度的性侵犯，但从未被迫发生性关系。那天晚上，一切都变了。
As Cameron began raping Colleen, Janice fled the room. Colleen could hear her crying and vomiting. Cameron stopped the assault and went to check on her. After that, Colleen was returned to her box in the basement. Although she was relieved that the rape was short-lived, Colleen knew it wasn't over. From that point on, Janice Hooker treated Colleen with increased cruelty. Based on Cameron's story about Janice being a former slave, Colleen had viewed her as another victim of the company. Yet, instead of being an ally, Colleen realized that Janice saw her as a threat to her relationship
当卡梅伦开始强奸科琳时，珍妮丝逃离了房间。科琳能听到她在哭泣和呕吐。卡梅伦停止了侵犯，去查看她的情况。在那之后，科琳被送回了地下室的箱子里。虽然她为强奸行为短暂而感到宽慰，但科琳知道这还没结束。从那时起，珍妮丝·胡克对待科琳更加残忍。基于卡梅伦关于珍妮丝曾是奴隶的故事，科琳一直把她视为公司的另一个受害者。然而，科琳意识到珍妮丝并没有把她当盟友，而是把她视为对自己与卡梅伦关系的威胁。
with Cameron. Eman's anger and hatred for Janice began to bubble away inside of Colleen. Months later in April, a blind-folded handcuffed Colleen was once again let upstairs. But she wasn't taken into the bedroom. Instead, for the first time in almost a year, she was met with the cool fresh air of night. Colleen's mind flooded with questions, but she knew better than to speak. Her captors led her to the front seat of a pickup truck where she was made to lay her head on Janus' lap. Then Cameron started driving. They'd only been on the road for about 15 minutes
伊曼对珍妮丝的愤怒和仇恨开始在科琳心中翻腾。几个月后的四月，戴着眼罩和手铐的科琳再次被带到楼上。但她没有被带进卧室。相反，近一年来她第一次感受到了夜晚凉爽清新的空气。科琳的脑海中充满了疑问，但她知道最好不要说话。绑架者把她带到一辆皮卡车的副驾驶座上，让她把头枕在珍妮丝的腿上。然后卡梅伦开始开车。他们在路上只开了大约15分钟，
when the car stopped. Colleen was let out of the truck and into a mobile home. Once inside, her blindfold and restraints were removed. The space was unfamiliar, but she recognized the hookers' water bed. With its black vinyl frame and steps that led up from the pedestal, she'd know it anywhere. Two panels had been removed from the foot of the bed, revealing the dark space inside the pedestal that the mattress sat on. Get in, Cameron ordered. Colleen lay on her stomach and worked her way into the narrow space under
车就停了。科琳被带下卡车，进入一辆移动房屋。进去后，她的眼罩和束缚被解开了。这个空间很陌生，但她认出了胡克夫妇的水床。那黑色的乙烯基框架和从底座上延伸出来的台阶，她一眼就能认出来。床脚处的两块板子被移开了，露出了床垫下方底座里的黑暗空间。“进去，”卡梅伦命令道。科琳趴在肚子上，钻进了床下狭窄的空间。
the bed. It was just longer than the length of her body. She managed to turn herself under her back. There was just two inches of space on either side of her, and if she bent her elbows, her fingertips touched the top of the box. A bedpan was already inside, but there was barely enough space for her to roll over or maneuver it under her. To the left of Colleen's head, a small air hole had been drilled into the floor of the mobile home, with another at her feet. This allowed a little air to filter in through her hose. The box was insulated by the frame of the water bed, muffling any sounds that came in or out. Within moments of crawling inside, Colleen's
它只比她的身体长一点点。她设法翻身仰卧。她两侧只有两英寸的空间，如果她弯曲手肘，指尖就会碰到箱子的顶部。里面已经放了一个便盆，但几乎没有空间让她翻身或在身下挪动它。在科琳头部的左侧，移动房屋的地板上钻了一个小气孔，脚部也有一个。这让一点空气可以通过软管过滤进来。箱子被水床的框架隔绝，消减了进出的任何声音。爬进去没过多久，科琳的
captors pushed the stairs back up against the base of the pedestal, locking her in and hiding the panel that led to her new prison. If the box in the basement had felt like a coffin, then this one felt like a tomb. Once again, Colleen was kept in the box for 23 hours a day alone with her thoughts and prayers. With minimal ventilation, she had to be mindful about when to use the bed pan, as the stench could be unbearable. Every evening, she was allowed to shimmy out to empty it, eat a basic meal, and drink
绑架者把楼梯推回底座底部，将她锁在里面，并隐藏了通往她新监狱的面板。如果地下室的箱子感觉像棺材，那么这个感觉就像坟墓。科琳再次被关在箱子里，每天23小时独自面对自己的思绪和祈祷。由于通风极少，她必须注意何时使用便盆，因为恶臭令人难以忍受。每天晚上，她被允许挪出来倒掉它，吃一顿简单的饭，喝
some water. Like before, this was then followed by a torture session. Although Colleen no longer had the workshop to keep her busy and provide some respite, the hookers sometimes allowed her to complete chores around the trailer. It was 64 feet long and 12 feet wide, with the combination living, dining, and kitchen space. There were two bedrooms, the main one where Colleen was kept and another down the narrow hallway that belonged to the hooker's young daughter.
一些水。和以前一样，随后是折磨环节。虽然科琳不再有工作室来打发时间并获得一些喘息机会，但胡克夫妇有时允许她在拖车里做家务。拖车长64英尺，宽12英尺，有客厅、餐厅和厨房的组合空间。有两个卧室，主卧是关押科琳的地方，另一个在狭窄的走廊尽头，属于胡克夫妇年幼的女儿。
Colleen could sometimes hear the sound of large trucks in the distance, leading her to conclude she was likely on the outskirts of town, not far from a highway. In the summer, Colleen was granted a pair of shorts, a singlet and some used tennis shoes. And for the first time, Cameron allowed her to go outside. Colleen relished the feel of the sun on her pale skin as she took in the unfamiliar surroundings. The trailer was parked at the end of a gravel road, one of several that dotted the surrounding remote landscape. The closest trailer sat around 200 feet to the east, with a highway 150 yards to the
科琳有时能听到远处大卡车的声音，这让她断定自己可能在城镇郊区，离高速公路不远。夏天，科琳得到了一条短裤、一件背心和一双旧网球鞋。这是卡梅伦第一次允许她到外面去。科琳享受着阳光照在苍白皮肤上的感觉，打量着陌生的环境。拖车停在一条碎石路的尽头，周围散布着几辆拖车，点缀着周围偏远的景观。最近的拖车在东边约200英尺处，高速公路在西边150码处。
west. Cameron escorted Colleen behind the trailer. There, she saw an open trench made to facilitate utility connections to the home. Cameron handed Colleen a shovel and ordered that she fill it with dirt. He also got to work as well. The two worked side by side all day, but this wasn't the taste of freedom Colleen had desperately longed for. Being capped in a near and mobile state had drained her body of strength and her limbs ate from the laborious task. The California sun also burnt her delicate skin, bringing more pain.
卡梅伦护送科琳到拖车后面。在那里，她看到了一条为方便房屋公用设施连接而开挖的沟渠。卡梅伦递给科琳一把铲子，命令她用土填满它。他也开始干活。两人并肩工作了一整天，但这并不是科琳渴望已久的自由滋味。长期处于近乎静止的状态耗尽了她身体的力量，她的四肢因繁重的任务而疼痛。加州的阳光也灼伤了她娇嫩的皮肤，带来了更多的痛苦。
Yet, Colleen soldiered on without complaint. Then out of nowhere, a mysterious man approached. To be continued, next week. The first to go missing was Micah. I need to get an officer out to my house. There's a woman that won't stop coming in my house. What is your name? My name is Micah. M-I-C-A-H. Two weeks after his disappearance, his friend James was murdered.
然而，科琳毫无怨言地坚持了下来。突然，一个神秘人出现了。未完待续，下周继续。第一个失踪的是迈卡。“我需要让警察到我家来。有个女人不停地闯进我家。”“你叫什么名字？”“我叫迈卡。M-I-C-A-H。”在他失踪两周后，他的朋友詹姆斯被谋杀了。
He was scared because he knew who shot him. And two weeks after that, their friend Bailey seemingly vanished. She is legitimately missing, like gone off the face of this earth. These three people knew each other and they're all either at this point dead or missing. Their three mothers began connecting the dots. We had no proof of anything. We just knew they were gone. Oh my God, this is bigger than we thought it was. What was uncovered was more devastating than anyone could have ever imagined.
他很害怕，因为他知道是谁开枪打死了他。两周后，他们的朋友贝利似乎也消失了。“她确实失踪了，就像从这个地球上消失了一样。”这三个人互相认识，此时他们要么死了，要么失踪了。他们的三位母亲开始把这些点联系起来。“我们没有任何证据。我们只知道他们不见了。”“天哪，这比我们想象的要大得多。”所揭露的一切比任何人想象的都要令人震惊。
Thought that they were just normal American couple, not knowing the type of underground world that they were living and the things that they were doing. They come off at very polite and well mannered, but they'll kind of throw before you can even blink an eye. It's one of the few times in my career where I've been warned, hey, you don't want to dig too deep on this one. Kidnap, torture, murder, and ultimately just memberment. They lived in a very great neighborhood, beautiful homes, nice people. That kind of stuff doesn't happen here. Oh yes, it does. And it's all connected to these crimes of guns and rates and everything else. There's
以为他们只是普通的美国夫妇，不知道他们生活在什么样的地下世界，也不知道他们在做什么。他们表现得非常有礼貌和教养，但他们会在你眨眼之前就……这是我职业生涯中为数不多几次被警告说：“嘿，你不想在这个案子上挖得太深。”绑架、折磨、谋杀，最终是肢解。他们住在一个非常好的社区，漂亮的房子，好人。那种事不会发生在这里。哦，是的，它确实发生了。而且这一切都与这些枪支、强奸和其他犯罪有关。有
something big about about what's going on. There's something, something crazy about this case. You know, I wouldn't chop up a friend of mine. I might cut a bullet this leg. I need to do everything that he tells me to do, and I need to do it now, and I need to do it fast, because if I don't, I'm next. I'm trying to be a good person, okay?
些关于正在发生的事情的大事。这个案子有些疯狂。你知道，我不会把我的朋友剁碎。我可能会切掉一条腿。我需要做他告诉我的一切，我需要现在就做，我需要快点做，因为如果我不做，下一个就是我。我试着做一个好人，好吗？
I want you to be a good person, too. Yeah, I should be a good person, and just confess all you to be a good person, too. Yeah, I should get a good person. I just confess all the same. I just come clean about everything. Just somebody tell me where they are. We will go give them. I will go dig. I will go dig and I will find them.
“我也希望你成为一个好人。”“是的，我应该成为一个好人，并坦白一切。我应该成为一个好人。我只是坦白一切。我只是把一切都交代清楚。只要有人告诉我他们在哪里。我们会去给他们。我会去挖。我会去挖，我会找到他们。”
I got a finder to hold her when last time. Even if it is just her bones. This is the story of the Baker's Field 3. her bones. This is the story of the Baker's Field 3. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“我上次找到她时，我得抱着她。即使只是她的骨头。”这就是贝克斯菲尔德三人的故事。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。